oster ruhe wieder gekippt worden
inzwischen haben mehrere
ministerpräsidenten bestätigt dass dem
so ist und auch davon gesprochen dass
angela merkel diese entscheidung wieder
zurückziehen wolle und dafür auch
verantwortung tragen holle wolle wie sie
das formuliert wie sie das begründet das
erfahren wir hoffentlich gleich wir
sehen im bundeskanzleramt ist schon
alles vorbereitet für ein statement der
kanzlerin
aber wir sehen auch dass die kanzlerin
noch nicht da ist sobald das der fall
sein wird sind wir natürlich live dabei
und nutzen die zeit aber bis dahin für
ihre und eure fragen und kommentare wie
immer in die kommentare oder gerne an
die eingeblendete e mail adresse ist
nicht eingeblendet aber sie doch da ist
außerdem ist sie ihnen bestimmt schon
gut bekannt wenn sie die zdf- heute- app
nutzen wir freuen uns also über ihre
rege beteiligung und damit hole ich
thoma 3 thomas reichert direkt mit ins
boot das ist unser zdf hauptstadt
korrespondent thomas es gab ja große
große kritik an diesen beschlüssen und
es gab auch schon in ansätzen die
überlegung dass es bald wieder einen
ministerpräsidenten runde geben soll
dass sie jetzt heute kommt und wie sie
kommt und mit dieser entscheidung wie
überraschend ist dass das ist total
überraschend damit hat niemand gerechnet
ich glaube ich noch nicht einmal die
ministerpräsidenten selbst haben damit
gerechnet ist eine reaktion auf diese
heftigen kritik insbesondere an der
regelung zur sogenannten coaster ruhe
da gab es kritik von seiten der
wirtschaft wo man sagte was soll das
wenn dir gründonnerstag und karsamstag
als ruhetage definieren dann rennen die
menschen dann an anderen zeitpunkten
umso mehr in die geschäfte zum beispiel
daneben am mittwoch und dann ist die
gefahr einer infektion nach viel größer
überhaupt gab es im nachgang gestern und
auch noch heute früh heftige kritik auch
vor dem ministerpräsidenten daran wie
diesen ministerpräsidenten runde der am
dienstag nacht überhaupt abgelaufen ist
bodo ramelow der thüringische
ministerpräsident erzählte davon der
sechs stunden lang auf einem bildschirm
geschaut hat
was ich gefragt habe wo eigentlich
merkel und die anderen
ministerpräsidenten sind also dass
vieles extrem schief gelaufen und das
jetzt da eine korrektur kommt also die
rücknahme der oster ruhe wohl für das
lasche inzwischen bestätigt hat dass
merkel oft mal angekündigt hat und was
sie gleich im kanzleramt verkünden wird
das ist ein singulärer vorgang das hat
es so bisher noch nicht gegeben und
zeigt wie sehr im grunde den kanzler der
bundeskanzlerin aber auch den
ministerpräsidenten dies das krisen
management dieser pandemie entglitten
ist es so dass der unmut der userinnen
und user groß ist und das bildet sich ja
auch in dem ab was man landauf und
landab gestern so gehört hat cengiz
sahin schreibt über youtube ein
regelrechter eiertanz niemand weiß mehr
woran er oder sie ist doch klar dass
manche rebellieren
peter koch schreibt über youtube ist ja
nur noch lachhaft franziska de schreibt
auch über youtube alles ohne sinn und
verstand die wissen selbst nicht mehr
wie sie uns noch ärgern können das ist
nur ein kleiner ausschnitt aus dem chat
den ich jetzt hier wieder gebe
und dann gibt's einen kommentar von
nicole fuchs über facebook die schreibt
einen fehler einzugestehen ist besser
als die fehlentscheidung einfach
durchzuziehen
dazu finde ich eine agentur die
berichtet dass armin laschet gerade eben
erst gesagt hat die rücknahme der
umstrittenen beschlüsse der politischen
kultur in deutschland gut thomas glaubst
du wirklich dass nach all dem was wir in
den letzten tagen und wochen gelernt und
erfahren haben dass positiv gesehen wird
wenn man diese entscheidung zurücknimmt
oder ist die zeit einfach vorbei in
denen das eingestehen von schwäche und
fehlern als stärker empfunden wird
also das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
früh das zu bewirkt habe ich finde
jedenfalls kann man natürlich sagen
viele eingestiegen und wir führen das
gespräch da kommt sie wir sprechen nach
er weiter meine damen und herren ich
danke ihnen dass sie heute mittag so
kurzfristig zeit gefunden haben hierher
zu kommen
ich habe mich zu diesem kurzen
pressetermin entschlossen weil ich heute
vormittag entschieden habe die
notwendigen verordnungen für die am
montag vereinbarte zusätzliche oster
ruhe also die ruhetage am gründonnerstag
und karsamstag nicht auf den weg zu
bringen sondern sie zu stoppen und es
klipp und klar zu sagen die idee eines
oster shutdown zwar mit bester absicht
entworfen worden
denn wir müssen es unbedingt schaffen
die dritte welle der pandemie zu bremsen
und umzukehren
dennoch war die idee der sogenannten
oster ruhe ein fehler
sie hatte ihre guten gründe war aber in
der kürze der zeit nicht gut genug
umsetzbar wenn sie überhaupt jemals so
umsetzbar ist dass aufwand und nutzen in
einem halbwegs vernünftigen verhältnis
stehen
viel zu viele fragen von der
lohnfortzahlung durch die ausgefallenen
arbeitsstunden bis zu der lage in den
geschäften und betrieben können das
haben die beratungen der letzten 24
stunden gezeigt jedenfalls in der kürze
der zeit nicht so gelöst werden wie es
nötig wäre und ob auch ein zweites klipp
und klar zu sagen
dieser fehler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler
denn am ende trage ich für alles die
letzte verantwortung qua amt ist das so
also auch für die am montag getroffene
entscheidung zur sogenannten osterroth
das habe ich den ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten vorhin auch in
einer kurzen video konferenz erläutert
und darüber auch die vorsitzenden der
fraktionen im deutschen bundestag
informiert und es ist mir wichtig dass
auch hier zu sagen ein fehler muss als
fehler benannt werden und vor allem muss
er korrigiert werden und ermöglicht hat
dass noch rechtzeitig zu geschehen
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung ausgelöst
das bedauere ich zutiefst und dafür
bitte ich alle bürgerinnen und bürger um
verzeihung
diese zusätzliche verunsicherung
bedauerlich umso mehr als wir uns dabei
bleibt es leider mitten in
durch die mutation ausgelösten dritten
welle der pandemie befinden ich danke
einmal mehr allen die mit ihrem
verhalten dazu beitragen die dritte
welle mit der tödlichen und ansteckenden
mutation des corona virus zu bremsen und
zu stoppen
dazu bietet der beschluss vom montag
auch ohne die sogenannte oster ruhe
einen rahmen mit der notbremse mit der
möglichkeit von regional zu
entscheidenden ausgangs begrenzungen und
kontakt beschränkungen mit dem ausbau
des testens natürlich auch mit der immer
weiter verstärkenden impfkampagne
am zwölften april werden die wir die
beratung fortsetzen und ich bin zutiefst
davon überzeugt wir werden das virus
gemeinsam besiegen
der weg ist hart und er ist steinig er
ist davon erfolgen aber auch von fehlern
und rückschlägen gekennzeichnet
aber das virus wird langsam aber sicher
seinen schrecken verlieren
und bis dahin setzen wir mit allen
maßnahmen weiter alles daran dass unser
gesundheitssystem der immensen belastung
standhält und zugleich die so überaus
großen folgen für wirtschaft bildung
kultur und für unser ganzes
zusammenleben aufgefangen werden
ich bitte sie um verständnis dass ich
jetzt keine fragen beantworten weil ich
gleich um 13 uhr den abgeordneten im
deutschen bundestag rede und antwort
stehen
herzlichen dank
tja ein bemerkenswertes statement der
bundeskanzlerin
sie hat bestätigt dass die oster ruhe
zurückgenommen wird sie wird gestoppt es
war ein fehler sagt sie es war eine idee
die mit bester absicht entwickelt wurde
aber einfach nicht umgesetzt werden kann
sie war nicht genug durchdacht zu viele
fragen bleiben offen und die zentrale
aussage war es war einzig und allein
mein fehler ich bitte die bürgerinnen
und bürger um verzeihung
thomas reichert ist unser korrespondent
in berlin unser hauptstadtkorrespondent
ich nehme an dass du unter einer langen
zeit als korrespondent und jetzt auch in
seiner zeit als hauptstadtkorrespondent
etwas ähnliches noch nicht erlebt hast
wer hat das auf dich gewirkt schon
wirklich bemerkenswert man hat es schon
gemerkt als sie reinkam und das kleine
publikum der der journalisten dass da
auf sie gewartet hat adressiert hat sie
wird den angefasst und betroffen in
gewisser weise wie gesagt eine frage
vorher was wie gut ist es einen fehler
einzugestehen und hilft das noch ich
würde sagen es ist zumindest besser
jetzt diesen fehler einzugestehen und
das auch als solches zu definieren wie
sie es hier macht und es ist natürlich
bemerkenswert dass sie sagt das ist um
das klipp und klar zu sagen es ist
einzig allein mein fehler qua amt in der
runde mit den ministerpräsidenten hat
gab es zumindest offenbar ein paar die
gesagt haben ja ja wir waren mit dabei
wir haben dem zugestimmt aber merkel
tritt das schon in besonderer weise nach
vorne lädt alle schuld auf sich und es
ist in gewisser weise natürlich auch
politisch klug und eine flucht nach
vorne
angesichts einer massiven kritik die da
nach dieser letzten
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auf die
bundesregierung auf die
ministerpräsidentinnen der länder
herr eingeprasselt ist es ist ja so wir
müssen glaube ich im vergleich noch alle
treffen zudem wie merkel vor einem jahr
gesprochen hat
zu beginn der pandemie als sie die
nationen der adressiert hat in einer
inzwischen fast schon historischen rede
und eingeschworen hat auf den kampf
gegen die pandemie
das hat haben alle ihr gefolgt
jedenfalls zu einem ganz großen teil
dass beide eine rede
das sagen heute noch virologen wo man
sofort gemerkt hat wie die ihre wirkung
entfaltet hat wie die leute zu hause
geblieben sind und sich an die regeln
gehalten haben
wir sind heute ein jahr später in einer
völlig anderen situation weil politik in
zentralen feldern der panik bekämpfung
so versagt hat bei tests beim kind bei
der kontakt verfolgung ist die
gefolgschaft die es vor einem jahr noch
gab eben nicht mehr da und deswegen ist
es vielleicht auch so dass merkel
gespürt hat dass ihr in dieser situation
gar nichts anderes übrig bleibt als
schnell diesen fehler anzuerkennen mit
aller demut und die menschen um
verzeihung zu bitten
thomas wenn ich hier in den chat gucke
dann lese und sehe ich viel respekt und
hochachtung vor dem was angela merkel da
gerade gesagt hat ein paar kann nicht
vorlesen
respekt wie gesagt eindrucksvoll
schreibt ein user auf youtube namens
hake links hoch voll schreibt über
youtube respekt frau merkel merkel ehren
frau kam hinten immer wieder lesen und
dann gibt es aber oder noch ein hier von
facebook von varinia kam auf die
schreibt trotzdem gut dass sie dafür die
verantwortung trägt das ist auch wieder
sehr sympathisch aber dann kommt
natürlich auch eine frage
beziehungsweise ein statement von peter
99 über youtube frau merkel sie haben
den zeitpunkt zum rücktritt verpasst nun
gehe ich nicht davon aus dass angela
merkel ein halbes jahr vor ihrem rückzug
aus der politik jetzt zurücktreten wird
aber normalerweise kennt man viele
eingeständnisse in der politik auch so
dass sie
personelle konsequenzen haben wie gesagt
lasst uns nicht nur über die kanzlerin
reden sondern insgesamt welche
konsequenzen lassen sich denn ziehen was
die verantwortung dieses beschlusses
angeht der ja auch von den
ministerpräsidenten mitgetragen worden
ist und von einem gremium das seit
mehreren monaten auch nicht mehr
wirklich überzeugen kann also christen
ja vielleicht noch ein satz vorher zu
der frage des rücktritts
das war offenbar tatsächlich ein thema
was da mit geschwungen hat es gab ein
paar ministerpräsidenten die gegenüber
medien extra darauf betont haben dass
ein rücktritt da jetzt nicht in frage
stehe und dass merkel nicht zurücktreten
werde
das lässt jeden beobachter aufhorchen
weil es ihr offenbar diese frage gab
sonst müsste man das nicht extra
thematisieren
es zeigt jedenfalls wie viel feuer
unterm dach und wie sehr diese kritik an
den beschlüssen und an der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz insgesamt
da die handelnden getroffen hat aber
natürlich hast du völlig recht es ist
nicht nur eine frage von vernarrten die
jetzt in der erklärung alle schuld und
alle verantwortung erst einmal auf sich
geladen hat sondern es ist dieses
gremium insgesamt dass sich gerade bei
der letzten konferenz dazu nimmt das als
dysfunktional gezeigt hat wurden
jedenfalls nicht mehr in der lage die
die gewaltigen probleme die es da gibt
wirklich gut zu adressieren und zu lösen
und hat stundenlang darauf verbracht auf
die frage ob es sein kontakt freien
urlaub in den küstenländern geben soll
es würde wenig darüber geredet wie man
dafür sorgen kann dass zum beispiel
kitas und schulen weiter auf bleiben
können indem man zum beispiel dafür
sorgt dass da ausreichend getestet wird
also es hat sich ja so eine art so ein
ungleichgewicht beide priorisierung der
themen und der der lösung vor allem der
pandemie probleme ergeben die zu einer
großen belastung nicht nur für dieses
gremiums und letztlich auch für den
glauben der menschen an die lösungs
fähigkeit und lösungskompetenz der
politik insgesamt haben
eine frage würde ich gern noch gerade
bei der unterbringung von einem
zuschauer namens jahren henrik schmidt
kunst der per mail schreibt wäre es
jetzt sinnvoll die kanzlerin die
vertrauensfrage stellen zu lassen
die frage des vertrauens die
vertrauensfrage ist ein mächtiges und
sehr existenzielles mittel das wirklich
nur in ganz seltenen fällen angewandt
wird und in der regel nur angewandt wird
wenn die gefolgschaft in der eigenen
fraktion und in der einen eigenen
regierungslager nicht mehr gegeben ist
davon ist im moment nicht so viel zu
sehen es gab am dienstag in der
fraktionssitzung der union
in der unter anderem heftige kritik auch
annette und an der bundesregierung
geäußert wurde da gab es mindestens
einen abgeordneten der da auch gesagt
habe ich kündige der bundesregierung das
vertrauen aus aber eine massive
absetzbewegung oder eine offene frage ob
diese regierung überhaupt noch eine
mehrheit im parlament hat die sehe ich
im moment nicht und das wäre aus meiner
sicht
und war es auch jedenfalls in der
vergangenheit immer voraussetzung dafür
dass man die vertrauensfrage stellt also
die situation dass die bundesregierung
im parlament keine richtige mehrheit hat
um ihre politik durchzusetzen die gibt
es im moment nicht und deswegen ist die
vertrauensfrage etwas was was jetzt sich
glaube ich im moment noch nicht so
stellt thomas an der stelle vielen dank
ich gehe davon aus so bleibt uns
erhalten hier im stream weil dieser tag
noch viel neuigkeiten mit sich bringen
wird und viele offene fragen auch noch
nicht beantwortet sind
aber ich würde die runde gerne erweitern
um unseren kollegen christian decker der
als rechtsexperte hier bei uns im studio
ist christian kannst du noch mal
erklären aus expertensicht was denn
diese runde aus ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten und
bundeskanzlerin überhaupt kann und was
sie eben auch nicht kann denn das ist ja
eine interessante frage vor allem vor
dem hintergrund wer jetzt über
hauptverantwortung wofür übernehmen kann
und soll
ja diese runde der bundeskanzlerin und
der ministerpräsidenten präsidenten die
wir derzeit ungefähr einem jahr kennen
die hat eigentlich keine juristische
kompetenz dass die regeln die dort
festgelegt werden sind in wirklichkeit
nur beschlüsse die eigentlich keinen
verbindlichen charakter haben
es ist so dass die länder nach dem
infektionsschutzgesetz die kompetenz
haben die regeln zu erlassen durch die
verordnungen die wir auch alle kennen
das heißt jedes bundesland selbst muss
eine eigene corona verordnung erlassen
und das was da drin steht nur das gilt
rechtsverbindlich es ist so dass diese
verordnung von den landesregierungen
erlassen werden
das heißt hier ist die exekutive am zug
die erlassen diese regeln die parlamente
sind nicht beteiligt und deshalb sind
die ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten in dieser runde mit
der bundeskanzlerin immer zusammen
es ist so dass die bundeskanzlerin als
vertreterin des bundes streng genommen
gar keine kompetenz hat in dieser runde
das heißt die bundeskanzlerin kann zwar
sagen was sie möchte und was ziele der
bundesregierung sind sie hat aber keine
kompetenz das wirklich umzusetzen in
eine verordnung das ist eben ländersache
das heißt die 16 ministerpräsidentinnen
und ministerpräsidenten die da
zusammensitzen
die müssen immer in den tagen nach einer
solchen runde in ihren
landeshauptstädten sich zusammensetzen
mit dem kabinett und müssen darüber
diskutieren welche regeln wollen wir wie
umsetzen und das führt auch dazu dass
haben in der vergangenheit immer wieder
gesehen dass die beschlüsse die in der
video konferenz mit der kanzlerin
getroffen wurden gar nicht in allen
ländern gleich gelten die 16
bundesländer weichen immer wieder davon
ab und es gibt immer wieder andere
auslegungen und andere regeln das heißt
daran sieht man auch dass das ein
föderales system ist wo die bundesländer
am ende selbst festlegen welche regeln
gelten sollen
nun hat man festgestellt eine woche ist
zu kurz um führen zum beispiel diese
oster ruhe dann so gesetzlich umzumünzen
dass das auch alles funktioniert nun ist
es alles wieder zurückgenommen worden
aber für viele unternehmen für alle
eigentlich war das ja jetzt eine große
frage wie hätten wir das überhaupt
umsetzen sollen
kannst du noch mal erklären was denn
jetzt hätte passieren müssen um aus
einem ganz normalen arbeitstag
ein ruhetag zu machen oder einen
feiertag hast du gerade erklärt hätte
man in den parlamenten machen müssen
aber auch für die unternehmen vor
welchen problemen entstanden die denn
jetzt stehen sie vielleicht jetzt weil
sie gestern war es angeschoben haben was
sie jetzt wieder rückgängig machen
müssen für die unternehmen ist das
tatsächlich ein großes problem das bei
oder kein großes problem sein dass man
jetzt gestern sich auf in der regelung
auf einen freien grund donnerstag
eingestellt hat und jetzt plötzlich am
nächsten tag alles wieder rückgängig
machen muss dass da stehen sicherlich
viele unternehmen vor praktischen
problemen und herausforderungen mann
hatte am gestrigen tag ganz gut gesehen
dass die politik selbst also namentlich
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten selber gar nicht so
genau wussten wie diese regelung
umgesetzt werden soll
also herr kretschmann aus
baden-württemberg oder her weil aus
niedersachsen haben gestern selber
gesagt dass sie eigentlich gar nicht so
genau wissen wie das juristisch gehen
könnte dass man den gründonnerstag und
karsamstag zu freien tagen macht und
juristisch gesehen ist das tatsächlich
auch kompliziert im prinzip gibt es drei
möglichkeiten wie man das machen könnte
man könnte über das feiertagsgesetz
einen solchen zusätzlichen feiertag
einführen
hier ist aber das große problem es gibt
nur einen einzigen feiertag in
deutschland der bundesrat gilt und das
ist der dritte oktober der tag der
deutschen einheit
alle anderen feiertage sind reine
länderkompetenz das heißt die
bundesländer selbst legen fest welches
sind die feiertage
das heißt man hätte die länder hätten
auf jeden fall probleme gehabt innerhalb
von wenigen tagen jetzt einfach an
zusätzlichen feiertag per gesetz
einzuführen das ist einfach das geht gar
nicht so schnell
die zweite möglichkeit wäre gewesen dass
der bund im infektionsschutzgesetz einen
solchen ruhetag ein führt nebenbei
bemerkt dieses wort ruhetag oder
ruhezeit dass das gibt es gar nicht also
das ist ja das ist gar nicht definiert
also man hätte auch erst mal definieren
müssen was es damit eigentlich gemeint
das wäre eine möglichkeit gewesen also
der bundestag tagt diese woche noch am
freitag tagt auch der bundesrat man
hätte das das hätte man theoretisch
machen können
die dritte möglichkeit wäre noch gewesen
dass die länder selbst das durch die
verordnung einführen
zwei freie tage aber und die
bundeskanzlerin hat das gerade im
statement auch gesagt die folgeprobleme
sind so unüberschaubar und es gibt so
viele fragen die man in der kürze der
zeit gar nicht
man kann also konkret zum beispiel was
passiert eigentlich wenn ich jetzt am
gründonnerstag trotzdem hätte arbeiten
müssen bekomme ich dann einen tag
jahresurlaub mehr am ende von meinem
arbeitgeber wird das dann bekomme ich
zwischen einen feiertagszuschlag von
meinem arbeitgeber wie ist das mit mit
schulferien es gibt drei bundesländern
in denen am gründonnerstag noch keine
schulferien waren bekommen die
schulkinder dann irgendwie einen
ausgleichs tag und so weiter und so fort
also das sind viele praktische fragen
und die bundeskanzlerin hat sich ja auch
genau auf diese offenen fragen bezogen
die sich jetzt in der kürze der zeit
einfach nicht klären lassen
also darüber müssen wir uns jetzt gar
nicht weiter auseinander setzen se vom
tisch wir gucken mal nach berlin in den
bundestag denn zu sehen ist soweit ich
weiß schon ein bild aus dem bundestag in
dem die kanzlerin in wenigen minuten
anlage deutsche bundestag hoffen dass
auch sein wird denn zum beispiel lese
ich hier schon
linken fraktionschef dietmar bartsch
appelliert an bundeskanzlerin merkel die
vertrauensfrage zu stellen also das was
gerade hier im chat schon geschrei
gefragt wurde von ihnen liebe userinnen
und user darstellt jetzt eben auch die
opposition das geht nur wenn die
kanzlerin das wort das vertrauen der
mehrheit des parlaments genießt sagte er
wir brauchen eine konsequente condomi
bekämpfung und das geht eben nur mit dem
parlament im rücken
wir sind sehr gespannt was da im
bundestag gleich zu hören sein wird
angela merkel wird sich erklären und die
opposition wird auch zu wort kommen in
der befragung christian reden wir
derweil noch ein bisschen darüber was
sehr interessanter weise diese
diskussion kurz vor mitternacht am
montag offenbar so hat eskalieren lassen
denn das war eigentlich die frage nach
urlaub auf mallorca konnte man sich
nicht irgendwie durchringen
das so zu regeln dass es einheitlich ist
dass es befriedigend ist für alle dass
die mindest
präsidentin hier sagen urlaub im eigenen
land nein urlaub auf mallorca ja
irgendwie können wir damit umgehen
wie ist denn da jetzt im moment die
rechtslage also die rechtslage ist im
moment die das reisen nach mallorca
erlaubt sind und es steht jetzt zur
debatte das eben eine solche test
pflicht eingeführt wird
es gibt ja mehrere möglichkeiten sage
ich mal aus biologischer sicht wie man
das risiko verringert dass menschen die
im urlaub waren und zurückkommen
das corona virus mitbringen sag ich mal
also der regel die jetzt lange für fünf
risikogebiete in geltung ist ist dass
man in der quarantäne muss und man kann
diese quarantäne verkürzen indem man
einen negativen pcr-test nachweist dann
muss man nicht die volle zeit in
quarantäne sondern kann diese zeit
abkürzen und für mallorca steht jetzt
zur debatte dass man das eben durch
einen test vor dem abflug nach
deutschland also vor beginn des
rückfluges ein test macht und dadurch
eine quarantäne umgehen kann
eine rolle eines eine sache die da eine
rolle spielt ist natürlich auch die dass
das vertrauen von menschen geschützt ist
juristisch auch geschützt ist die jetzt
einen urlaub gebucht haben
in dem glauben mallorca ist kein
risikogebiet das heißt wenn ich
zurückkomme aus mallorca muss sich nicht
in quarantäne und diesen menschen jetzt
sozusagen nachträglich aufzuerlegen in
quarantäne zu müssen das hat ja für
einzelpersonen hat das sehr gravierende
folgen also wenn ich arbeitnehmerin
arbeitnehmer bin und ich komme dann aus
dem urlaub zurück und dann muss ich noch
mal fünf tage oder länger zu hause
bleiben und muss quasi zusätzlichen
urlaub nehmen das ist ja eine große
herausforderung und das kann auch für
die arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber
kann das ein großes problem werden das
ungeplant leute dann bei der arbeit
nicht erscheinen und da versucht man
jetzt eine lösung zu finden
in dieser in diese richtung das sind
weil du den biologen oder den
infektiologen gerade angesprochen hast
dann holen wir doch einen dazu wir
freuen uns nämlich dass professor
thorsten leer und über skype
zugeschaltet ist professor für klinische
pharmazie an der universität des
saarlandes und sie sind in den letzten
wochen und monaten damit beschäftigt zu
modellieren was passiert in der
infektion wenn man was vor öffnet oder
schließt
herr professor lehr bevor wir über oster
ruhe oder über oster unruhe sprechen
lassen sie uns ganz kurz bei mallorca
bleiben
was halten sie denn als infektiologe von
oster urlaub auf mallorca
ja also wir haben vor allem in der
vergangenheit im letzten jahr gesehen
dass die ganzen urlauber eigentlich und
die reiserückkehrer für uns ein großes
problem dargestellt haben das heißt sie
sind natürlich relativ unkontrolliert
wieder zurückgekommen und haben dann die
infektion wieder verbreitet und relativ
viel öl ins feuer jetzt auch der zweiten
welle gekippt von daher bin ich jetzt
kein großer freund von urlaub auf
mallorca also sicher vielleicht sein mag
und den einzelner erscheinen mag halte
ich doch für ein relativ großes risiko
für die gesamtbevölkerung
es gibt ja die meldung über die
brasilianische mutation auf mallorca für
wie gefährlich halten sie das ja das ist
natürlich ein großes problem wenn wir
uns die letztendlich als
reisemitbringsel anfang haben wir hier
in deutschland ein großes problem weil
die bis jetzt noch nicht verbreitet ist
wir wissen noch nicht richtig wie sie
sich durchsetzen wird hier auch gegen
die britische im moment scheint es soll
sei die britische dominant aber die
frage passiert natürlich was passiert
dann wenn alle geimpft sind und
zumindest die impfung scheint gegen die
britische variante gut zu wirken dann
wird sich die frage stellen setzten sich
dann andere varianten durch und wenn wir
letztendlich die brasilianische variante
hier in deutschland haben besteht auch
die möglichkeit dass sich dann
entsprechend durchsetzt also ich denke
da ist vorsicht geboten die
brasilianische variante bietet relativ
viel negatives potenzial hier auch
nochmal neues feuer in dieser premier
einzubringen wofür soll ich würde gerne
einmal in den chep die frage stellen was
denn die userinnen und user über ostern
vorhaben was haltet ihr was hatten sie
geplant wolltet ihr sowieso eure
kontakte einschränken wollten sie
die familie treffen und überlegen das
jetzt nicht zu machen oder doch zu
machen die frage würde mich
interessieren
schreibt uns also gerne eure fragen und
kommentare
ihre und eure fragen und kommentare in
den chat herr professor lehr
was ist denn ihre meinung als experte
wäre ein oster ruhetag am gründonnerstag
sinnvoll gewesen aus pandemischer sicht
oder nicht weil die leute dann eben am
mittwoch und am samstag umso mehr mobil
gewesen wären oder hätten sie gesagt
doch das ist ein zeichen dass geht
darüber hinaus nur einen tag dicht zu
machen das ist auch ein signal die lage
ist ernst und das hätten sie befürwortet
ja also wir haben uns nach dem beschluss
ganz lange die köpfe zerbrochen was das
eigentlich bedeutet ich glaube da gibt
es verschiedene auslegungen wird das
laufen könnte
zum einen hätte es natürlich was bringen
können wenn die leute sich daran halten
das heißt also wenn sie es auch wirklich
als ruhephase nutzen
die frage wird dann eben nur sein was
ist dann am ostersamstag mit den
einkäufen irgendwann werden diese
einkäufe erledigt und auf der anderen
seite bietet dieser zusätzliche ruhetag
natürlich auch die möglichkeit sich
wieder im privaten zu treffen was ich
für relativ gefährlich inhalte aufgrund
der aktuellen situation
von daher sind wir endlich zu der zu dem
beschluss gekommen dass es eigentlich
wahrscheinlich gar nichts bringen würde
dass wir eine art nullsummenspiel
aber wir hatten eine gewisse
verschiebung der aktivitäten und
infektionsgeschehen wir glauben nicht
dass es etwas bringt außerdem muss man
auch sagen dass fünf tage eigentlich
viel zu wenig sind um diese pandemie
wirklich in den griff zu kriegen
zumindest solange noch ein gewisses
grundrauschen ohne grund mobilität
herrscht solange keine komplette
ausgangssperre herrschte werden dort
auch infektions stattfinden und vor
allem über ostern wo auch treffen in den
privaten erlaubt sind trotzdem auch wenn
eingeschränkte gehe ich davon aus dass
sie ähnlich wie an weihnachten
stattfinden werden da haben wir auch
gesehen dass die infektionszahlen und
deutlich angestiegen sind über
weihnachten und silvester und das
gleiche erwarte ich jetzt eigentlich
auch über ostern deswegen gilt vor allem
den appell wirklich in die bürgerinnen
und bürger noch mal zu richten dass sie
jetzt diese ruhephase diese aufgehobene
ruhephase nicht als eine aktivität war
es interpretieren sondern hier wirklich
auch zur ruhe finden und auch die
treffen möglichst einschränken
die antworten auf die umfrage im chat
sind sehr gemischt
es gibt viele die sagen wir werden genau
das versuchen die kontakte
einzuschränken
andere hatten vor die familie zu treffen
vielleicht kann ich ein paar mal sammeln
einer schreibt über youtube zu hause
bleiben markus steinberg schreibt über
youtube ich werde wohl zu meinen
schwiegereltern fahren denn die kinder
haben sie seit einem jahr nicht gesehen
das kommt natürlich hinzu dass das ja
jetzt nicht das erste mustern ist dass
man so erlebt sondern die situation gibt
es jetzt schon seit mehr als einem jahr
paylife schreibt über youtube grillen
mit der familie smi am rädchen schreibt
über youtube ich wollte zu meiner
familie fahren und diese besuchen das
werde ich nun nicht tun
moralität schreibt über youtube ich
fahre einen tag zu meinen eltern nicht
weit entfernt und schießt frank schreibt
über youtube ich hätte gerne ostern
gefeiert oder wir sehr gerne mit dem
motorrad nach italien in die berge
gefahren halt wie immer also ein
durchaus gemischtes bild vielen dank für
diese kommentare und schreibt bitte
gerne einfach weiter was ihr vorhabt an
ostern herr professor lehr
sie haben gerade gesagt dieser eine tag
hätte sowieso nichts gebracht was würde
denn aus ihrer sicht etwas bringen was
müsste denn getan werden was wäre denn
ein gutes ergebnis gewesen
nachts um 2 uhr 30 in dieser montag
nacht nach der letzten mpk ja also ob
also meine entscheidung nachts um 2.30
sind selten gut
von daher weiß ich nicht gut die aus
dieser ministerpräsident ohne waren aber
ich hoffe sie hatten einen klaren kopf
als ich um diese uhrzeit aber ich denke
es hätte deutlich mehr genutzt werden
wir vielleicht auf andere sicht
vielleicht noch uns gedanken gemacht
hätten
wie wird zum beispiel die schnelltests
in den schulen besser aus rollen können
wie wir die schulen letztendlich auch
ein sicherer machen
aber wie wir auch letztendlich
verpflichtende tests glücklich in die
arme
letztendlich in die üblichen die
behörden sondern in die firmen
eingetragen hätten an den arbeitsplatz
dass wir sicherlich gut gewesen
wir dürfen nicht vergessen wir haben
nicht auch noch ein ganz wichtiges
mittel zur zur hand das heißt also ich
denke die ausgangs beschränkungen sind
in meinen augen noch relativ einfache
mittel die zumindest ohne großen ja
gesamtwirtschaftlichen schaden
einhergehen haben ab war natürlich fasst
das freiheitsrecht angeht eine große
einschränkung sind die aber zumindest
den anderen pandemischen regionen wie
zum beispiel großbritannien auch gut
geholfen haben das wären sicherlich
einfacher
schritte gewesen die mit jahr weniger
geld monetären einheiten letztendlich
bezahlt hätten werden müssen aber dafür
mit einschränkung von freiheitsrechten
also ich denke wir müssen was machen das
werden wir sehen die infektionszahlen
steigen deutlich an sie wir hatten
gestern weder 16.000 neuinfektionen und
die zahl wird weiter steigen die
britische variante ist auf dem vormarsch
und ich glaube was wir sagen müssen ist
dass wir auf jeden fall als bürgerinnen
und bürger jetzt auch diese selbst test
nutzen sollten falls wir diese oder auch
schnelltests fällst du eben besucher an
ostern plan vor allem mit der familie
da möchte ich dringend dazu raten dass
wir uns dort auch regelmäßig testen auch
nicht nur einmal sondern halt auch
wiederholt aber weil diese infektion
natürlich auch erst also also
mathematisch auftreten kann und wir
wirklich unsere lieben schützen müssen
herr professor lehr wenn es gleich im
bundestag in die fragestunde geht
vielleicht können wir das bild gerade
nochmal zeigen aus berlin dann wird
natürlich auch das ein thema sein
ich höre das bild gibt es gerade nicht
aber sie kennen den bundestag aller
liebe nach hinten und zuschauer dann
wird natürlich auch darum gehen was es
mit dem testen warum funktioniert das
nicht
und was ist mit dem impfen und dazu
würde ich gerne mal gemeinsam mir einen
tweet angucken von unserer brüssel
korrespondenten stefan leifert rüdiger
vielleicht kannst du ganz kurz auf den
auf das notebook notebook hier im studio
schalten hier ist es stefan hat
getwittert vor einer stunde eklat um
astrazeneca inspektoren im auftrag der
eu kommission finden in einem
italienischen apfel werk nahe rom 29
millionen impfdosen die astrazeneca
bisher geheim hielt und offenbar vor
allem nach großbritannien gehen sollten
die eu kommission verlangt nun
rechenschaft
also man denkt ja es wundert einen gar
nichts mehr aber das ist natürlich schon
noch mal ein starkes stück er professor
lehr
nicht nur dass wir weniger impfstoff im
land haben als wir eigentlich hätten
haben sollten und jetzt sowas wie ihre
macht sie das ja das ist natürlich
wirklich bedauerlich dass hier sehr viel
politik und teilweise wohl auch
preispolitik gespielt wird oben
letztendlich diesen impfstoff der uns
natürlich eigentlich ja allen zur
verfügung stehen sollte wir haben
deutlich zu wenig impfstoff wir sehen
dass wir impfen jede woche nur mit
ungefähr einer million info
pro woche das ist viel zu wenig um
wirklich diese pandemie auch nur
ansatzweise in der nächsten zeit in den
griff zu kriegen
herr scholz einmal zehn millionen
impfungen pro woche versprochen das
wären faktor von 10
da sind wir momentan weit von entfernen
diese 29 millionen impfdosen würden uns
in deutschland sehr gut tun
beantwortet ganz kurz an dieser stelle
eine frage von eimer 2.0 wird die
bundestagsdebatte live übertragen
ja genau das haben wir vor wir wissen
nur noch nicht genau wann es losgeht
aber wir werden auf jeden fall dabei
sein
ab 13 uhr fünf etwa wenn angela merkel
dort sich erklären wird und das wird
natürlich auch interessant sein zu sehen
wie die reaktionen darauf dann sind herr
professor lehr an dieser stelle erst mal
ganz herzen der herzlichen dank auch sie
bleiben uns denke ich erhalten an diesem
tag aber ich würde gerne erstmal noch
hier im studio mit christian decker
darüber sprechen
ostern ist auch reisezeit normalerweise
wie ist denn im moment die situation wo
darf ich denn überhaupt hin und wo darf
ich nicht hin und welche bedingungen
gibt es aktuell also um ehrlich zu sein
man muss jetzt einmal abwarten was die
länder für verordnung erlassen
also nach diesen treffen am montagabend
werden jetzt verordnungen der länder
erlassen und da muss man eben genau rein
gucken was steht da drin
es spricht sehr vieles dafür dass reisen
auch im inland oder vor allem im inland
nicht erlaubt sein werden
es wird aber natürlich reisen im ausland
sind möglich im moment nach jetzigem
kenntnisstand also nach mallorca und hat
auch in andere gebiete die nicht zum
risikogebiet erklärt wurden vom robert
koch institut darf man nach jetzigem
stand reisen wieder die regelung aber
konkret sein werden das muss man glaube
ich jetzt einmal noch mal abwarten
warum ist es denn eigentlich so schwer
und zwar nicht zwölf monate nach beginn
der pandemie sondern von mir aus im
zweiten oder dritten monat zu sagen
jeder der nach deutschland einreist egal
von wo muss einen test machen da muss
man noch klären wer den bezahlt die
fluglinie oder die person privat oder
das unternehmen das diese person auf
dienstreise geschickt hat oder wer auch
immer
aber warum gibt es diese regelung
und ich ist es so schwierig also
juristisch gesehen oder
verfassungsrechtlich müssen solche
regelungen immer der sogenannten
verhältnismäßigkeit entsprechen
das heißt man darf keine regelungen oder
in diesem fall eine testpflicht leuten
auferlegen wo das einfach außerhalb dass
außer dass sie jetzt verhältnisses steht
man kann es nur machen wenn sie ein
risikogebiet ist weil dann ist eine
grundlage dafür da aber man könnte nicht
grundsätzlich sagen wir machen es
generell so ist es und es gab in den
vergangenen zwölf monaten dazu auch
gerichtsentscheidungen in
nordrhein-westfalen zum beispiel da
wurde eine eine testpflicht kürzung
seiner quarantäne pflicht für verbrecher
widrig erklärt weil es eben für den
betroffenen unverhältnismäßig ist wenn
er aus einem nicht risikogebiet einreist
dass er dann trotzdem sich in quarantäne
begeben muss das heißt hier die gerichte
überprüfen tatsächlich jeder einzelne
corona maßnahme und so klein diese die
regeln auch sind alles unterliegt einer
gerichtlichen kontrolle
das ist glaube ich auch eine wichtige
nachricht in diesen zeiten wo es viel
unsicherheit gibt und wo es ständig neue
regelungen gibt vollständig neue
verordnung in kraft treten
und man irgendwann so ein bisschen den
überblick verliert aber alle regelungen
sie unterliegen einer gerichtlichen
kontrolle das heißt wenn man sich
dagegen wehrt vor gericht wird das
gericht dass auch überprüfen und das zum
beispiel hat das wurde jetzt gerade
heute ein urteil veröffentlicht
da ging es darum das wann ist eine
menschenansammlung wann handelt es sich
um eine menschenansammlung in dem
konkreten fall stand ein 4 personen für
mehrere minuten zusammen auf der straße
die sich zufällig getroffen hatten und
die sollten an einem bußgeld bezahlen
weil sie gegen die korona verordnung
verstoßen haben da hat das gericht
gesagt nein das fällt definitiv nicht
unter einer menschenansammlung wenn man
sich zufällig trifft und eben nur für
ein paar minuten mit abstand im freien
miteinander spricht dass also als
konkretes beispiel dafür dass eben alle
diese regeln ganz minutiös oder
millimetergenau von den gerichten
überprüft werden
christian vielen dank bis hierhin mit
einer frage von tobias 1995 auf youtube
gehe ich noch mal zu unseren kollegen
thomas reich hat nach berlin denn tobias
de stellt die frage zdf heute
nachrichten was ist jetzt mit dem
gründonnerstag
ich komme da nicht mehr mit thomas ich
glaube diese frage kann man inzwischen
beantworten gründonnerstag ist kein
ruhetag so wie er gestern noch ein
geplanter ruhetag gewesen wäre
aber bei allem anderen kommen wir auch
nicht mehr so richtig mit oder wir
blicken in den bundestag wo die
kanzlerin in kürze sich erklären wird
was ist denn zu erwarten also auf die
frage des users das kann man immerhin
klar beantworten diese brewster ruhetag
regeln gründonnerstag und karsamstag
dass es gekippt da bleibt alles beim
alten
ansonsten gelten die regelungen der
beschlüsse von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von montag
auf dienstag nacht unter anderem auch
die möglichkeit für länder und regionen
ausgangs beschränkungen einzuführen und
verschärfte kontakt beschränkungen aber
das sind wie gesagt kann bestimmungen
das ist im moment noch nicht
bundesweit so geregelt dass ist für
regionen in denen die inzidenz über 100
ist eine möglichkeit da einzugreifen was
für moment sehen ist im bundestag die
vorbereitungen für die
regierungsbefragung das ist ein
instrument des bundestages bilder
sondern mittwochs in sitzungswochen da
ist wenn am vormittag das kabinett
getagt hat dort beschlüsse getroffen hat
dann hat das parlament als erstes die
möglichkeit die regierung dazu zu
befragen
da ist dann meistens immer ein minister
da und besonders interessant ist es
natürlich wenn die bundeskanzlerin da
ist so wie es heute der fall ist
tagesordnung ist gerade beschlossen
worden was ganz schäuble hat die mit der
übrig üblichen kuhn und monoton stimme
da abgelesen
es müsste im grunde jeden moment
losgehen und dann wird es interessant
denn der linken-fraktionschef bartsch
hat aufgrund der vorkommnisse unter sich
überschlagenden ereignisse heute
vormittag schon gefordert dass merkel im
bundestag die vertrauensfrage stellen
soll
das ist für eine oppositionspartei ein
legitimes vorgehen auf ein
verständliches
aber es ist natürlich so dass eine ein
fehlen der parlamentarischen mehrheit
für merkel und ihre regierung im moment
weit und breit nicht in sicht ist aber
immerhin zeigt dass die krisenhafte und
aufgeheizt die stimmung im moment in
berlin ist diese frage greift auch
nochmal der user die über youtube auf
wird merkel die vertrauensfrage stellen
also das taucht hier in der tat oft auf
vielleicht muss man in dem fall
vertrauensfrage anders definieren denn
es geht nicht nur um das vertrauen des
bundestages sondern um das vertrauen des
volkes der bürgerinnen und bürger die
der kanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten jahr folgen müssen
in den entscheidungen und nachvollziehen
müssen
wie will man denn wieder herstellen dass
die bürgerinnen und bürger ihr vertrauen
darin haben vielleicht bekommen wir
jetzt eine antwort von angela merkel
denn wir sehen
sie begibt sich zum rednerpult gehirn
rein die macht vom platz die große
vorsitzende der fraktion der gold des
deutschen bundestages und anschließend
auch die öffentlichkeit davon
unterrichtet dass ich heute vormittag
entschieden habe die notwendigen
verordnungen für die zusätzliche
sogenannte oster ruhe also die ruhetage
am gründonnerstag und karsamstag nicht
auf den weg zu bringen sondern sie zu
stoppen
ich möchte diese entscheidung auch hier
zu beginn dieser regierungsbefragung
noch einmal erläutern zunächst die idee
eines oster shutdowns war mit bester
absicht entworfen wurden
wir müssen es unbedingt schaffen die
dritte welle der pandemie in der wir uns
gerade befinden zu bremsen und
umzukehren
dennoch daran kann es keinen zweifel
geben war die idee der sogenannten oster
ruhe ein fehler
sie hatte ihre guten gründe war aber
jedenfalls in der kürze der zeit nicht
gut genug umsetzbar wenn sie überhaupt
jemals so umsetzbar ist dass aufwand und
nutzen in einem halbwegs vernünftigen
verhältnis stehen
viel zu viele fragen von der
lohnfortzahlung durch die ausgefallenen
arbeitsstunden bis zu der lage in den
geschäften und betrieben können das
haben die letzten
24 stunden gezeigt jedenfalls in der
kürze der zeit nicht so gelöst werden
wie es nötig wäre
und um auch ein zweites klipp und klar
zu sagen
dieser fehler ist einzig und allein mein
fehler
denn am ende trage ich für alles die
letzte verantwortung das ist qua amt so
also auch für die am montag getroffene
entscheidung zur sogenannten oster ruhe
ein fehler muss als fehler benannt
werden vor allem muss er korrigiert
werden und wenn möglich hat das noch
rechtzeitig zu geschehen
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich
gleichwohl weiß ich natürlich dass
dieser gesamte vorgang zusätzliche
verunsicherung ausgelöst hat das
bedauere ich zutiefst und dafür bitte
ich auch von dieser stelle noch einmal
die bürgerinnen und bürger und auch sie
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen um
verzeihung
diese zusätzliche verunsicherung
bedauerlich umso mehr als wir um als wir
uns und dabei bleibt es leider mitten in
der in dieser schärfe
insbesondere durch die mutationen
ausgelösten dritten welle der pandemie
besinnen und ich möchte deshalb einmal
mehr all denen danken die mit ihrem
verhalten dazu beitragen die dritte
welle mit der tödlichen und ansteckenden
mutation des corona virus zu bremsen und
zu stoppen
dazu bietet der beschluss vom montag mit
den ministerpräsidenten auch ohne die
sogenannte oster ruhe einen rahmen mit
der notbremse mit der möglichkeit von
regional zu entscheidenden ausgangs
begrenzungen und kontakt beschränkungen
mit dem ausbau des testens und natürlich
auch mit der sich immer weiter
verstärkenden impfkampagne
ich bin zutiefst davon überzeugt wir
werden das virus gemeinsam besiegen
der weg ist hart und steinig er ist von
erfolgen aber auch von fehlern und
rückschlägen gekennzeichnet
aber das virus wird seinen schrecken
verlieren
und bis dahin müssen wir mit allen
maßnahmen weiter alles daran setzen dass
unser gesundheitssystem der immensen
belastung standhält und zugleich die so
überaus großen folgen für wirtschaft
bildung kultur und für unser ganzes
zusammenleben aufgefangen werden dabei
danke ich allen die mir persönlich
genauso wie der bundesregierung
insgesamt auch heute wieder ihre
unterstützung angeboten haben
ich danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit und
stehen jetzt für ihre fragen zur
verfügung
die erste frage gestellt der kollege dr
kurt schritt curio auf dem zweiten märz
gibt er kein geschäft wieder an personen
mit migrationshintergrund genauer
moslems machten auf den corona
intensivstationen über 50 prozent aus er
meint das ist ein echtes problem aber es
ist ein tabu
er sieht eine gruppe die die politik mit
corona warnungen überhaupt nicht
erreicht er spricht dann von moscheen
und sagt weiter
da sind parallelgesellschaften mitten in
unserem land bekommen wir nicht rein
diese gruppe besteht aus vier millionen
menschen
das erinnert an die super special events
arabisch türkischer große hochzeiten und
beerdigungen hotspot bei fastenbrechen
bei türkeireisen erklären warum wird
diese gruppe der regel verweigerer nicht
gezielt adressiert warum nicht mit
maßnahmen gegengesteuert ist die
erzählung vom multi kulti erfolgsmodell
wichtiger als die bekämpfung des virus
ist die bürger wegzusperren geschäfte
und betriebe ruinieren okay aber gewisse
verursacher mal einen blick zu nehmen
die den staat nicht respektieren für
diese regierung nicht opportun wollen
sie hier nicht eingreifen vielleicht ja
jetzt am gründonnerstag ich habe gute
stoffe
ich möchte mich als erstes und ich
glaube im namen von vielen hier dagegen
verwahren ganze gruppen von menschen in
millionenzahl in einer art und weise zu
verdächtigen die das vollkommen
inakzeptabel ist
zwei breaks gehen wir natürlich allen
fragen wo und wie besondere
infektionsgeschehen nachzuvollziehen
sind nach und die bundesregierung
informiert deshalb auch in deutscher
sprache chemie und genauso in vielen
anderen sprachen
ich selber habe schon ausländischen
medien auch interviews gegeben oder
türkischsprachigen medien besser als
deutsches medium aber ein
generalverdacht hilft uns hier überhaupt
nicht weiter und die von ihnen zitierten
zahlen auf die agile angeblich bezug
genommen haben sind vermischt zwischen
zitaten von den wiener und scheinbaren
fakten die so überhaupt nicht benannt
wurden nachfrage
vielen dank
sie glauben als ich einen eigenen
wissenschaftlichen beratern nicht mehr
frage zur oster ruhe wenn jetzt
überhaupt nicht mehr bedacht werden die
frage der lieferketten der dringenden
krankenhaus termine der
unternehmenskosten wenn sie sich in
ihrer beim kopf durch die wand in ihrer
eigenen politik der lockdown
verschärfungen kopflos verhindern weil
sie es nicht anders kennen obwohl es
nicht greift ist es dann nicht mehr eine
frage von nicht verantwortung oder
verzeihung sondern müssten sie nicht
nach artikel 68 die vertrauensfrage
stellen oder wagen sie das nicht mehr
angesichts dieses koalitionspartners ich
habe meinen worten von eben nichts
hinzuzufügen
die nächste frage stellt die kollegen
mit familie spd sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin
angesichts der gerade von ihnen ja
nochmal bestätigten rücknahme der
ruhetags regelung zu ostern zusätzlich
frage ich mich natürlich schon welche
alternativen maßnahmen sie sehen und wir
alle wissen dass wir den bürgerinnen und
bürgern derzeit sehr viel abverlangen
und zwar nicht nur in form freiwilliger
selbstverpflichtung sondern eben auch in
form von grundrechts einschränkungen
gleichzeitig wissen wir um die bedeutung
der testung als brücke zu einer
möglichst schnellen endgültigen imf
erfolgsstrategie aber insgesamt müssen
wir doch feststellen dass wir die
kontakte und nicht zuletzt auch am
arbeitsplatz versuchen müssen unter
kontrolle zu halten meine konkrete frage
an sie daher lautet würden sie das
teilen dass wir anstelle weiterer
grundrechts einschränkungen der
bürgerinnen und bürger womöglich so
etwas wie ausgangs beschränkungen viel
dringender ist geboten wäre und längst
überfällig wäre dass wir arbeitgeber
zweimal wöchentlich zu einer testung
verpflichten anstatt auf freiwilligkeit
zu setzen
also ich glaube dass es ja einen quasi
paradigmenwechsel fast gegeben hat in
den zu uns zur verfügung stehenden tests
wir haben neben den pcr test ja schon
eine ganze weile die antigen
schnelltests aber bei näherer
betrachtung trotz aller pilotversuche
trotz aller möglichkeiten dass das auch
durch nicht medizinisch geschulte
sondern nur kurz geschulte menschen
stattfinden kann haben sie sich
letztlich nicht durchgesetzt ich will
das nicht bewerten aber durch die selbst
test haben wir jetzt eine neue situation
diese selbsttests werden jede woche noch
weitere präparate zugelassen so dass man
in endlicher zeit darüber sprechen kann
dass sie ausreichend zur verfügung
stehen wir müssen priorität jetzt erst
einmal die selbst für die kitas und
schulen verwenden
und leider ist es auch hier heute noch
nicht so dass dort eine flächendeckende
tests um zwei mal die woche stattfindet
wir haben dann mit den arbeitgeberinnen
mit den arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgebern verabredet
dass sie bis anfang april und eine
beteiligung statistik vorlegen an den
tests in den betrieben die sind absolut
notwendig und die bundesregierung hat
gesagt wenn das monitoring der
arbeitgeber aber auch unser eigenes
monitoring nicht ausreicht werden wir
dann anfang april entscheiden ob für
regulatorische maßnahmen im sinne der
arbeitsschutzverordnung noch durchführen
müssen
es wird also dann zeitnah erfolgen ich
halte die tests in den betrieben für
außerordentlich wichtig und die
bestätigung über diese tests kann dann
auch verwendet werden um bestimmte
zugangsmöglichkeiten auch im sonstigen
leben zu bekommen
das ist eine ganz wichtiger punkt und
das dritte sind die tests zentren zu
jedem bürger der bundesrepublik
deutschland und jeder bürgerin jeden tag
eine jede woche mindestens einen test
zur verfügung steht und ich will noch
mal darauf hinweisen auch wenn ich meine
zeit jetzt überzogen habe dass die
möglichkeit dessen was man zum beispiel
jetzt in tübingen macht überall in
deutschland gemacht werden könnte dem
steht nichts entgegen und wir aber
nochmal ausdrücklich vereinbart haben
bestimmte einzelne testgebiete in den
bundesländern auszuweisen und man das
auch zu erproben nachfrage
ja wir reden ja aber nicht davon dass es
hier um das freiwillige und selbst
gewählte einkaufen oder zum friseur
gehen geht sondern tatsächlich um eine
verpflichtung die arbeitsvertraglichen
grundlagen hat deswegen stellt sich
schon die frage inwiefern wir nicht am
arbeitsplatz hier auch mehr vorsorge
leisten müssen es gibt dort
betriebsärzte die das gut begleiten
können es geht also nicht nur um selbst
test sondern auch tatsächlich um die
durchführung von entsprechenden
schnelltests verstehe ich sie richtig
dass sie aber hier durchaus erwägen und
zu sagen dass sie bei einer
entsprechenden nicht ausreichenden
wöchentlichen testung am arbeitsplatz ab
april hier eine andere
arbeitsschutzverordnung zustimmen würden
wir jetzt den tag im april ihren und ich
abschließend sagen aber in der ersten
hälfte das ab jetzt wird diese
entscheidung getroffen und wir sind
bereit auch regulatorische maßnahmen
durchzuführen
denn die beteiligung nicht ausreichen
die nächste frage stelle kollege dr
marco buschmann fdp
sie haben uns hier gerade erläutert dass
sie einen ihrer fehler von gestern als
solchen erkannt haben dass sie ihn
korrigieren und dass sie dafür um
verzeihung bitten
das findet glaube ich breiten respekt
aber entscheidend ist ja jetzt welche
konsequenzen daraus gezogen werden indem
man sich beispielsweise von einem
entscheidungs mechanismus trend der
systematisch auf die produktion von
fehlern angelegt ist und daher frage ich
sie
wann hören sie endlich auf zu versuchen
hinter verschlossenen türen im ganz
kleinen kreise mitten in der nacht
übernächtigt ohne rücksprache
möglichkeit mit praktikern oder
mitmenschen mit sachverstand mit den
ministerien über das leben von millionen
von menschen zu entscheiden wann legen
sie die entscheidung zurück in die hände
der parlamente
schauen sie wenn es solche
verschlossenen runden wären wie sie es
beschreiben dann wäre ja vielleicht
manchmal auch gar nicht so schlecht aber
das ist leider nicht der fall aber jetzt
zum ernst der frage die ja ich sehe den
kern schon ich habe extra eben immer
einen einführenden worten auch gesagt
dass sich alle die einbeziehen möchte
die mich unterstützen möchten und dazu
zähle ich auch den deutschen bundestag
jedenfalls in seiner großen breite in
welcher form das besser gelingen kann
darüber muss weiter nachgedacht werden
die runden mit den ministerpräsidenten
sind trotzdem notwendig und weil vieles
auf der basis des
infektionsschutzgesetzes was in diesem
parlament ja verabschiedet wurde auch
dann durch verordnungen umgesetzt sein
muss aber das eine schließt das andere
nicht aus
nach vielen dank ich möchte trotzdem
noch mal nachfragen
wir haben es ja zum teil mit mikro
management zu tun hier ging es um
feiertagsregelung hier ging es um fragen
für die es hier im parlament qualitäts
sicherungsmechanismen gibt die sind auch
nicht neu die muss man auch nicht
erwägen deshalb frage ich noch mal wann
wollen sie damit aufhören solche fragen
des technischen mikromanagement
übernächtigt mitten in der nacht im
kleinen kreise zu entscheiden und
dorthin zu geben wo es hingehört na ja
also ich würde schon mal sagen dass so
wie hier im parlament sachverstand ist
auch in der bundesregierung sachverstand
ist bei den ministerpräsidenten
sachverstand ist das zeichnet unsere
föderale ordnung glaube ich aus auch sie
regieren ja in einigen ländern mit und
wissen dass die frage wie man bestimmte
entscheidungen in einer so
außergewöhnlichen situation wie in einer
pandemie trifft muss immer wieder neu
betrachtet werden ich glaube es gibt
schon sehr viele sehr sehr gute und
gemeinsam getragene entscheidungen mit
den ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten und über die
verbesserungen der arbeitsweise das
haben wir uns heute in der runde auch
gesagt müssen wir noch einmal werden wir
auch noch einmal miteinander reden
die nächste frage steht bettina wiesmann
cdu csu
frau bundeskanzlerin das instrument der
eigenen tests ist auch nach meiner
auffassung ein game changer für die
weitere pandemie bekämpfung
voraussetzung dafür dass glaube ich
abnehmen ist eine ausreichende zahl von
eigenen tests am markt und
zielgerichtete sichere prozesse in der
anwendung
ich bin auch wie sie der auffassung dass
schulen und kitas der best mögliche
anwendungsbereiche hierfür sind weil die
organisation einfach und die kosten
überschaubar sind und dass man auf
diesem weg einen großen teil der
gesellschaft 25 millionen menschen leben
in familien mit minderjährigen kindern
einen großteil normalität sehr schnell
zurückgeben könnte meine frage was
unternimmt die bundesregierung um
klarheit zu schaffen oder
sicherzustellen dass genügend eigene
tests verfügbar sind und diesen bereich
auch fokussiert zur verfügung gestellt
werden
und was unternimmt die bundesregierung
um die zuständigen länder dafür zu
gewinnen und wie sind die reaktionen
also es ist sicherlich nicht die
vorrangige aufgabe der bundesregierung
jetzt im blick auf die schulen zu
handeln nichtsdestotrotz haben wir wegen
der markt macht die man auch entfalten
kann wenn länder gemeinsam mit der
bundesregierung bestellvorgänge auslösen
folgendes vereinbart das funktioniert
auch gut die taskforce testen aus dem
gesundheitsministerium und dem
verkehrsministerium das ja für logistik
verantwortung trägt hat sozusagen eine
plattform organisiert über diese
plattform werden bestellungen
abgewickelt die länder haben
verantwortliche benannt die für diese
beschaffung der tests verantwortlich
sind und ist es so dass die bundesländer
vor wenigen tagen erklärt haben dass sie
für die monate märz april über diese
plattform genügend tests selbst test
bestellt haben und für den
augenblicklichen moment im blick auf
schule und kita keinen weiteren bedarf
sehen zum teil haben die bundesländer
das ja auch alleine bestellt das ist mal
die situation deshalb besteht trotzdem
diese taskforce weiter sie kann
jederzeit aktiviert werden nachfrage
habe ich mein halt das mikrofon muss man
schalten für die frau kollegin weiß man
ja dass mit hier geschaltet jetzt müsste
gegensatz zu tragen dankeschön
bisher ist die rede von zwei tests pro
woche als zielmarke die für die test
gesicherte öffnung von schulen
angestrebt wird nach meiner auffassung
würde eine tägliche testung hohe
prozesssicherheit und auch maximal
möglichen schutz schaffen und damit
sowohl vertrauen bei schülern eltern und
lehrern als auch mehr unbeschwertheit im
schulalltag ermöglichen befürwortet die
bundesregierung befürworten sie diesen
clan und kraftvollen weg also wir haben
bis jetzt uns auch darauf kapriziert das
wird auch von den ländern so gesehen
dass eine zweimalige testung aus unserer
sicht ein hohes maß an sicherheit
bringen würde sicherlich würde eine
dreimalige testung noch ein etwas
höheres bringen nagel als modell ihrer
hat uns das noch mal gezeigt aber die
tests sind etwa einen tag ja valide
insofern sagen sie muss man jeden tag
neu testen
man muss dann aber auch aufwand und
nutzen abwägen experten sagen uns dass
zweimal eigentlich schon ein hohes maß
an sicherheit brächte es wäre nur gut
das würde schon durchgeführt das will
ich ausdrücklich sagen dass da sind wir
ja noch nicht und warum die zweimal man
sagt wenn ich das richtig verstehe dass
eine generation zeit dieses virus immer
fünf tage beträgt das heißt wenn man
alle vier tage testet drei tage vier
tage dann hat man jedenfalls schon einen
großen erfolgsfaktor
die nächste frage stellte
fraktionsvorsitzender die linke dietmar
bartsch
sie haben hier davor auch der
öffentlichkeit gegenüber ihren fehler
eingestanden haben verantwortung
übernommen haben sie entschuldigt das
verdient zweifelsfrei respekt wäre im
übrigen dankbar
dennoch mitglieder ihres kabinetts
ähnlich handeln würden daher ist im
großen und ganzen gut gegangen denke da
zum beispiel auch an herrn steuer aber
ehrlich gesagt angesichts der
dramatischen situation also die von der
union wissen sie ihre fraktion
da wird immer dringend raten und ändere
jetzt meine frage ich mal dringend raten
dass sie sich von denen und von der spd
die gewissheit geben dass sie das
vertrauen hier im parlament noch haben
wenn das was da gerade abläuft
das ist wirklich inakzeptabel wir haben
eine situation dass viele menschen nicht
mehr können und dann gibt es derartige
qualitäts lose zwischenrufe versichern
sie sich bitte der unterstützung weil
ansonsten die unterstützung in der
bevölkerung nicht mehr gegeben ist dass
sie die unterstützung ihrer fraktion und
auch der sozialdemokratischen fraktion
haben und wollen sie da wollen sie
wollen sie wirklich
auf die insel
gerade so viel applaus wie wenig ich
weiß auch gar nicht wahrscheinlich weil
bislang mit oder wie ist das schön mit
klatschen die anderen auch mit die hier
gerade bei ihnen verhaltensauffällig
geworden sind aber ich stelle ja der
bundeskanzlerin frage lange ich kann
mich ersetzen eine einheit einen
traumblick warten anderes war die
nachfrage des kollegen lothar barth wir
dürfen darauf antworten sie würde diese
diese frage trotzdem gerne noch stellen
wollen weil das ja auch ja auf ihr
kabinett verwiesen weil da höre ich sind
großen und ganzen gut gegangen
ich habe von herrn steuer nie ein
eingeständnis gehört dass millionen
versenkt worden sind beim auto und bei
ähnlichen finden sie dass ihr verhalten
für die mitglieder ihres kabinetts der
maßgeblich sein sollte oder finden sie
das nicht
ich habe jetzt heute erst mal mein
verhalten hier dargestellt und ich
glaube dass ansonsten die
kabinettsmitglieder nach besten wissen
und gewissen ihre arbeit machen
die nächste frage stellt die
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90/die
grünen katrin göring eckardt
frau bundeskanzlerin vielen dank für
ihre erläuterung vielen dank dass sie
deutlich gemacht haben dass sie einen
fehler eingestehen ich habe davor sehr
hohen respekt das ist auch ein dienst an
der demokratie ich sage das ohne aber
und auch ohne klamauk
gleichwohl sind wir in einer sehr
schwierigen situation die dritte welle
rollt und wir brauchen einen
wellenbrecher und sie haben wir deutlich
gemacht dass aktuell einiges gilt von
dem was in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz beschlossen
worden ist
ich frage sie dennoch sind sie nicht der
auffassung dass sich dieses format als
das entscheidungs format überlebt hat
dass wir hier im deutschen bundestag mit
rede und gegenrede mit transparenz mit
argumenten deutlich machen müssen womit
können wir diese welle tatsächlich
brechen es ist hochgefährlich
die frage sehr konkret wo geht es darum
dass weitere büros zu gemacht werden
dass die betriebe runtergefahren werden
wo noch nicht getestet werden kann was
offensichtlich so ist was es mit den
körpernahen dienstleistungen wie sorgen
wir dafür dass die tests tatsächlich an
den schulen ankommen wie sorgen wir zum
beispiel dafür dass der pnv sein angebot
aus leitet damit es dort nicht mehr eng
wird wir würden noch viel mehr einfallen
wie sorgen wir dafür dass wir einen
stufenplan haben damit wir nicht ad hoc
entscheidungen haben sondern planvolles
behalten
ich finde es sehr gut wenn sie einen
vorschlag machen könnten den wir hier im
parlament debattieren könnte
also erstens will ich mitteilen dass ich
den titel der regierungserklärung
erweitert habe auch auf bitte auf bitten
des der fdp dass wir morgen nicht nur
über den europäischen rat sondern auch
über die beschlüsse der mpk sprechen
zweitens haben wir einen stufenplan
beim letzten mal als mit der mpk
vereinbart er ist eine sehr gute
grundlage aus meiner sicht und hat uns
ja auch in die lage versetzt dann die
notbremse zu aktivieren weil sie leider
in vielen bundesländern notwendig ist
ich bin sehr froh dass das auch von den
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
akzeptiert wurde und dass wir darüber
hinaus noch anregungen für weitere
regionale maßnahmen machen können wie
wir überhaupt in zukunft regionaler
vorgehen müssen ich bin bereit vieles zu
verantworten die verteilung von selbst
an schulen gehört wirklich nicht zu der
aufgabe die eine bundesregierung leisten
kann der haben 40.000 schulen in
deutschland wir haben dann ist
wir haben kommunale
selbstverwaltungsorgane wir können
vieles machen aber jede ebene in der
demokratie hat ihre verantwortung wir
sind bei der beschaffung der selbst fest
mit unterstützend tätig aber alles kann
nicht die bundesregierung machen das
sage ich ganz ausdrücklich
ich könnte jetzt des bundestags
präsidentin könnte ich noch zu dem öpnv
oder haben wir den ländern geld zur
verfügung gestellt und zwar ziemlich
viel geld ich habe jetzt die genaue
milliarden zahlen nicht im kopf aber
frage dort liegt und können wir gerne
nach reichen um genau das angebot im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr und im
schülerverkehr auszuweiten ich habe das
vielfach um nicht zu sagen gefühlt
hundertfach gesagt dass da etwas
geschehen muss und manche machen es
andere woanders ist noch
nachbesserungsbedarf bedarf auch daran
muss darüber muss gesprochen werden
zumal die britische mutante und das ist
der unterschied zu früher nun wirklich
bei kindern und jugendlichen
erwiesenermaßen gefährlicher ist und wir
den schutz der schulen weit mehr in den
vordergrund stehen müssen als bei dem
ursprünglichen virus nachfrage das mikro
wird von hier geschaltet deswegen müssen
sie warten bis rot leuchtet und sich
darauf aber auch nicht kritisiert werden
wenn es noch nicht geschaltet ist ja es
ist ja gut weg
das müssen sie sich ja noch machen soll
wird wohl nicht drin das ist also der
moment der stille
den haben wir jetzt erlebt frau
bundeskanzlerin ich will dann noch
einmal sehr konkret nachfragen wir
brauchen wir jetzt eine notbremse wald
jetzt freut die dritte welle und jetzt
ist die gefahr dass unsere
intensivstationen überquellen werden und
deswegen die frage wann werden sie
vorlägen offensichtlicher der mpk und
nicht uns aber wann werden sie vorlegen
was die alternativen sind für das was
jetzt nicht geschieht mit den anderthalb
fünf tagen ruhe
welche möglichkeiten gibt es zusätzlich
und zusatz zu dieser frage tests und
schulen
das problem ist ja dass sie
offensichtlich nicht da sind und
zuständigkeiten hin oder her und
-verteilung auch hin oder her aber
zunächst mal müssen sie ja bereit
gestellt sein dass sie auch da sind und
ich erlebe ich jedenfalls dass ein sehr
sehr vielen schulen gerade für kleine
kinder diese tests auch nicht zur
verfügung stehen
geschweige denn dass sie richtig
verteilt werden und deswegen habe ich
die frage gestellt es gibt ja die
taskforce sind genügend test da die
tatsächlich ankommen
ich höre von eltern von lehrer/innen
dass sie nicht da sind muss noch erhalt
sagen dass die bundesländer erklärt
haben dass ihre ihr bedarf ob der jetzt
in jedem fall schon geliefert wurde das
kann ich nicht nachprüfen da sind zum
teil auch lieferzeiten aber dass ihr
bedarf für die bestellung von selbst des
gedecktes zweitens wir reden seit
monaten über das testen an schulen haben
einen modellversuch in hessen gehabt wie
auch mit den antigen schnelltests
getestet werden kann bis vor kurzem
waren die antigen schnell dass das
einzige und auch beste was uns zur
verfügung stand sie werden in
testzentren angewandt man kann um
hilfestellung bieten dann auch in den
schulen zum teil muss das und auch in
den betrieben wird man nicht alles
gleich sofort mit den selbst test machen
weil sie noch nicht in ausreichender
menge für alle drei säulen des testen
zur verfügung stehen deshalb wird in dem
bürger test auch weiterhin der antigen
schnelltest verwendet und aus diesem
grunde sage ich ich kann mich doch nur
auf die antwort der länder verlassen
wir bestellen jederzeit nach wenn die
länder der meinung sind dass sie mehr
an den selbsttest braucht die nächste
frage stellt gerade auch die frage nach
der nach der was kann gemacht werden um
die dritte welle zu brechen erst einmal
eine ganz konsequente umsetzung der
notbremse das heißt zurück zu den
kontakt beschränkungen die wir vor bis
zum 7 märz hatten das muss dann auch
umgesetzt sein und zweitens haben wir
extra ein punkt 3 der entwickler des mdk
beschlusses andere wege aufgezeigt die
je nach politischer überzeugung
eingesetzt werden können die aber
gleichermaßen auch gut sind das sind
weitere kontakt beschränkungen oder
ausgangs begrenzung will an der stelle
einmal darauf hinweisen dass solche
ausgangs beschränkungen in ganz vielen
ländern europas gang und gäbe sind
niederlande frankreich großbritannien
irland portugal
es ist also man muss es nicht nachmachen
aber man muss irgendwas machen und das
ist vollkommen klar und das ist die
antwort auf frau göring-eckardt
ich möchte das nicht bundesweit
vorschreiben weil wir hier ganz
unterschiedliche politische
überzeugungen haben und wenn sich das
nicht als ausreichend erweist dann muss
man auch über gesetzgebungsprozesse
darauf läuft ja ihre frage hinaus
nachdenken
danke sie jetzt steht die nächste frage
ihr kollege albrecht glaser afd
frau bundeskanzlerin
der artikel 3 111 nv einer der beiden
europäischen verträge sagte in seinem
absatz 2 ich zitiere der eu haushalt
wird unbeschadet der sonstigen einnahmen
vollständig aus eigenmitteln finanziert
für den wiederaufbau vor der eu soll bis
2024 über 800 milliarden euro als
darlehen darlehen der eu aufgenommen
werden
also verstoßen die kommission der rat
die bundesregierung und dieser bundestag
gegen das primärrecht der eu wenn sie
morgen den vorgelegten eu eigenmittel
beschluss unterstützen können sie den
bundestag und der deutschen
öffentlichkeit erklären wie dieses
vorgehen mit ihrem amtsverständnis zu
verankern ist ja gerne isst gern die sie
sagen genau einen eigenmittel beschluss
und das ist ja das worauf sie auch im
artikel 311 uv hingewiesen haben und
diese eigenmittel beschluss wird
einstimmig und jeweils durch die
nationalen parlamente verabschiedet und
alle mitgliedstaaten müssen das
gleichermaßen tun und damit passiert
genau das was auch ganz wichtig ist dass
nämlich die hoheit auch für bestimmte
kompetenzen und dazu gehört das
haushaltsrecht in den nationalen
parlamenten verankert ist und mit dem
beschluss des deutschen bundestages
sowie am morgen geplant ist ist dann
genau das was notwendig ist auch
eingehalten
also nicht umsonst denn eine frage
stellen zu dürfen umsonst heißt das was
wir morgen beschließen einen eigenmittel
beschloss stellen so verehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin leider keine juristische
diskussion nicht führen
aber der eigenmittel beschluss kann
keine rechtsgrundlage seien für die
darlehensaufnahme der eu da sagen 25.000
professorin
ich stelle meine zweite frage der
wiederaufbau von der wieder- aufbau vor
ist ein schulden finanzierter transfer
zwischen den mitgliedstaaten
das schreibt der bundesrechnungshof in
diesen tagen im jahr 20 12 haben sie
erklärt eine gesamtschuldnerische
haftung in der eu wird es nicht geben
solange ich lebe
zitat ende im artikel 9 absatz 5 des eu
eigenmittel beschlusses ist genau eine
solche haftung deutschlands für die
schulden anderer eu staaten vorgesehen
sie bedrängt mindestens 80 milliarden im
ungünstigsten fall beträgt sie 8 100
milliarden euro
wie können sie den bundestag und der
deutschen öffentlichkeit ihren
sinneswandel erklären und diese zumutung
für das hoch und und die zumutung für
das hoch verschuldete land deutschland
herr kollege glaser generell erteilt der
bundestagspräsident das wort auch zu
nachfragen also wenn sie immer warten
bis ich denen das wort für die nachfrage
gebe habe frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
diese nachfrage gehört ja also wir reden
hier über elemente des eu haushaltes und
nicht über eine europäische vorgang der
dann zum schluss durch das europäische
parlament gefunden werden müsste sondern
es wird genau durch die nationalen
parlamente gemacht dadurch ist es eine
verantwortung oder eine übertragung von
zuständigkeiten durch beschlüsse des
nationalen parlamentes auf die
europäische union und damit gewinnt es
das element eines haushaltes oder den
charakter eines haushaltes und eu
haushalte haben immer das
der unterschiedlichen verteilung
zwischen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union es gibt nie
deshalb nennt man uns ja nettozahler und
andere sind nettoempfänger es gibt nie
einen haushalt der das was das
mitgliedsland 11 11 wieder herausbekommt
dass es gerade der sinn des haushaltes
damit wir auch kommissions- elemente
haben also im elemente des
zusammenwachsens innerhalb der
europäischen union weil wir davon
überzeugt sind dass eine bessere
wirtschaftliche kohäsion und kohärenz
auch vorteile für mitgliedsstaaten
bringt die heute wirtschaftlich stärker
sind weil sie sozusagen zb durch den
binnenmarkt uns ganz andere chancen
einräumen als wenn wir ganz alleine
wären diese frage stellt der kollege
dennis rohde spd vielen dank herr
präsident frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
ja heute nicht nur eine mpk sondern sie
haben im kabinett auch eckwerte
finanzplanung an den nachtragshaushalt
auf den weg gebracht in einer
pressemitteilung der unionsfraktion vom
montag heißt es zum nachtragshaushalt
es stellt sich aber die frage ob bei den
ausgaben des bundes noch maß und mitte
gelten
ich würde gerne von ihnen wissen ob sie
die auffassung der fraktion teilen ob
sie die ausgaben die sie auf den weg
gebracht haben für angemessen erachten
falls sie die kritik teilen würde ich
gerne wissen wo sie weniger gerne
verausgabt hätten die schwerpunkte sind
der wirtschafts hilfen und der
gesundheitsbereich und damit verbunden
die frage wann immer so gerät wird ist
sein zitat die schulden des
finanzministers tragen sie den
nachtragshaushalt auch mit den schulen
die darin verankert sind mit ich mache
das auch gerne zu den gemeinsamen
schulden das der bundeskanzlerin und des
bundesfinanzministers es sind im
wesentlichen schulden die wir den
deutschen steuerzahler zumuten das muss
unser verständnis seien also wieder ist
das sind die steuereinnahmen noch die
steuerausgaben unser eigentum sondern
wir tun das nach bestem wissen und
gewissen der die pressemitteilung so
weit ich sie verstanden habe herr oder
enthält eine frage und so wie wir es von
selbstbewussten haushaltspolitikern
kennen ist es nicht die einzige frage
die der bundesregierung gestellt wird
insofern wird auch diese beantwortet
werden ich als diejenigen die heute mit
zugestimmt hat glaube das maß und mitte
gewahrt sind
nachfolgende wurde da sie ja sicher auch
zu den eckwerten bekannt haben in den
erklären ist ein politischer
handlungsrahmen der finanzplanung von 20
milliarden in den nächsten jahren noch
vorgesehen wir wissen dass ab 20 sind
sich jetzt dass ein politischer
handlungsbedarf von 20 milliarden der
noch geschlossen werden muss darüber
hinaus beginnt ab 20 26 die volle
tilgungsleistung von 19 milliarden im
jahr halten sie es unter anbetracht
dieser herausforderung für den bestehen
für realistisch umsetzbar dass man den
soli in gänze abschafft dass man da eine
unternehmenssteuerreform macht und dass
man den wm etat drastisch erhöht ich
glaube da sind ja nur drei elemente ich
könnte noch fünf andere nennen die auch
noch zu erfüllen sind ich glaube dass
wir im augenblick in einer zeit leben in
der wir sehr schwer überblicken können
welche wachstumsmöglichkeiten wir haben
und wie sich die steuereinnahmen in den
nächsten jahren entwickeln werden
insofern ist die mittelfristige
finanzplanung natürlich jetzt mit noch
mehr unsicherheiten behaftet als sie es
normalerweise ist ich finde es erstmal
sehr beruhigend dass wir eine rücklage
von glaube ich 48 milliarden euro haben
mit der wir in den nächsten jahren auch
noch umgehen können und wir haben uns ja
nicht leichten herzens aber ich glaube
der von uns beiden gemeinsam geteilt
noch einmal entschlossen dass wir die
aussetzung der schuldenbremse
entsprechend artikel 115 grundgesetz
noch einmal in anspruch nehmen das finde
ich auch in der sache gerechtfertigt
dadurch können wir die rücklage dann
ihnen darauf folgenden jahren mit
einsätzen und dann wird man sehen wie
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung ist
hauptsache hoffentlich gut und wir
werden sicherlich wenn ich mir die
schnelligkeit unserer entscheidung auch
unserer investitions genehmigung und so
weiter anschauen
in den nächsten jahren noch viel arbeit
haben hier auch ein bisschen mehr
geschwindigkeit in das ganze staatliche
handeln zu bringen das zeigt uns die
pandemie auf
die nächste frage stellt der kollege
oliver luksic fdp frau bundeskanzlerin
eben wurde ja nach ihrer task force für
schnelltests gefragt und da sie sich ja
mit zahlen offensichtlich gut auskennen
möchte ich da noch mal nachfragen da ist
drin der verkehrsminister der hat
hunderte millionen euro an steuergeldern
bei der mord versenkt die masken
beschaffung die war doch jetzt wohl
offensichtlich alles andere als effektiv
und kosteneffizient von provisionen mal
ganz zu schweigen
es hat jeder discounter in deutschland
besser hingekriegt als die
bundesregierung und ausgerechnet diese
beiden kümmert sich jetzt um die
schnelltests was ihr offen sich auch gar
keine test strategie vorliegt deswegen
ist meine frage im fußball wenn es eine
heftige niederlagen serie gibt da wird
man bevor man an einem trainerwechsel
denkmal überlegen welche anderen spieler
man mal ein wechseln kann
deswegen ist meine frage an sie was muss
passieren wie hoch muss der schaden sein
bevor sie ihre aufstellung im kabinett
mal ändern
schauen sie es sind die minister in
dieser task force und die ministerien
die dafür zuständig sind das sind
diejenigen die mit logistik zu tun haben
und der gesundheitsminister
zweitens wenn sie auf die masken
beschaffung noch mal zurückkommen
das eine ist dass da dinge passiert sind
die sind zu verurteilen und das hat die
unions fraktion nun auch ausgiebig und
wie ich finde ein sehr beachtlicher art
und weise ich bin ja auch mitglied
dieser fraktion getan und es hat sich
der übergroße mehrzahl dieser fraktion
auch dazu bekannt dass das was wir getan
haben wir in unseren eigenschaften als
abgeordneten getan haben wenn wir uns
für die beschaffung von masken
unterstützend eingesetzt haben und jetzt
will ich sie noch mal erinnern und es
ist immer so wenn eine notsituation ist
dann kann es gar nicht schnell genug
gehen und ich kann mich an keinen
discounter in deutschland erinnern der
irgendeinem krankenhaus irgendeine maske
geliefert hat ich kann mich nur daran
erinnern
dass wir ganz ähnliche berufe bekommen
haben wo kommen übermorgen über
übermorgen und ein überübermorgen die
masken her
das war die situation damals wir haben
daraus die schlussfolgerung gezogen wir
haben inzwischen eine eigene deutsche
fertigung und anderen europäischen
ländern das auch gemacht für masken
getan wir haben uns unabhängiger gemacht
wir haben uns hier besser aufgestellt
und wir haben damals dort von masken
bekommen waren haben viele dazu
beigetragen dass sie zu bekommen waren
das ist marktverzerrung gab in so einer
knappheit situation das sollte sie nicht
verwundern aber mit dem blick von heute
ohne jedes hineinversetzen in die zeit
von damals dinge zu beurteilen das ist
aus meiner sicht zumindest sehr fraglich
ob das der wahrheit in vollem umfang
genüge wird ich bin froh dass wir heute
eine andere situation bezüglich der
maske und man kann wird auch an anderen
stellen der gesamten pandemie fragen ob
es immer der effizienteste weg war
daraus wird man später nochmal lehren
ziehen müssen
also ich entnehme ihrer äußerungen dass
sie alles als richtig empfunden haben
dass alles gut gelaufen ist und dass man
wahrscheinlich auch im
gesundheitsministerium alles wunderbar
auch mit rechten dingen zusammen
gelaufen ist nun meine frage ist was
muss denn eigentlich passieren
wie hoch mobil muss das denn was muss da
überhaupt was sie nicht mag hat in einem
schuhgeschäft da hat der der unternehmer
muss muss sagen muss schließen weil die
hilfen bis heute nicht angekommen sind
das liegt ja nicht am geld das liegt an
der bürokratie das geld ist ja da und
deswegen ist meine frage an sie was muss
passieren dass sie da eingreifen ihr
minister altmaier hat gesagt es solle
keinen job verloren gegen gegen korona
tanja hunderttausende unternehmer
selbständige arbeitnehmer die um ihren
job bangen und liegt an der bürokratie
was muss passieren dass sie da
eingreifen
ich beschäftige mich ihnen takt damit
damit das auch ganz klar ist und mit dem
was die minister tun und was auch die
unterdrückung hilfen und ähnliches an
dank dass da vieles länger dauert als
wir uns das alle wünschen ist klar dass
aber jeden tag auch aus den kreisen des
parlaments nachbesserungswünsche kommen
ist auch klar
richtigerweise bei der mehr sachverstand
einfließt was vielleicht noch nicht
ausreichend berücksichtigt wurde
und insofern hat manches länger gedauert
was sie auch bedauere aber was auch
wieder mehr möglichkeiten gebracht hat
ich denke nur mal an die lagerbestände
in textilgeschäften und ähnliches dass
das mit abgerechnet werden kann und
deshalb weiß ich was wir den
unternehmerinnen oder auch den
geschäftsleuten und den
kulturschaffenden und vielen anderen
zumuten in dieser pandemie aber unser
gegner ist das virus das dürfe man nicht
vergessen dass hat keiner von uns hier
angeschafft und deshalb können wir immer
unsere prozesse optimiert ich weiß wie
viele beamte aufrufe hochtouren in
dieser pandemie arbeiten und ich weiß
wie viele minister auf hochtouren
arbeiten obwohl was nicht optimal läuft
muss verbessert werden
dazu hat man auch die opposition die
darauf hinweist marion wendt cdu csu
stellt die nächste frage
frau bundeskanzlerin
zunächst muss ich ihnen meinen tiefen
respekt und meine anerkennung
aussprechen weil ich glaube in diesem
land ist etwas verloren gegangen nämlich
das nennt sich fehlerkultur sie haben
die verantwortung getragen das haben sie
gesagt für einen fehler der gemacht
wurde
ich glaube aber auch und das hat michael
kretschmer auch vor wenigen minuten
gesagt dass die gesamte
ministerpräsidenten runde hier diesen
fehler trägt deswegen will ich zumindest
sagen sie tragen nicht allein die
verantwortung für diesen fehler jetzt
geht es deswegen aber nach vorne zu
schauen
dieser fehler ist korrigiert es ist
erledigt und jetzt geht es vor allen
dingen analyse zu betreiben wie auch wir
besser werden können
viele menschen unserem land sind seit
zwölf monaten konsequent konkret die
ganze zeit im kampf gegen dieses virus
der unsere gegner nämlich ist im kampf
da denke ich an das drk das thw die
malteser die bundeswehr alle die im
einsatz sind beim impfen beim testen was
einfach den ganzen tag läuft das muss
man auch einfach mal sagen in diesem
land und deswegen meine frage ganz
konkret wie sie sich auch vorstellen
können im rahmen von lessons learned wie
eine mögliche bewertung neubewertung
neuaufstellung des bevölkerungsschutzes
und zivilschutzes in diesem land
aussehen könnte auch mit den erfahrungen
die wir gemacht haben in den letzten
zwölf monaten das nicht alles gut ist
ist klar
aber ich glaube es ist wichtig jetzt
auch daraus zu lernen ja erst einmal
danke dass sie das erwähnen die erwähnt
haben die jeden tag wirklich tag und
nacht kann man sagen neben dem
medizinern und dem krankenschwestern und
krankenpfleger oder krankenpflegerinnen
und krankenpflegern um es etwas
zeitgemäßer zu sagen dass sie darauf
hingewiesen habe welche ehrenamtlichen
organisationen wir hier auch haben und
mit welcher hilfe die in dieser pandemie
uns zur seite stehen und das gilt aus
geordnet zu gewürdigt zu werden auch in
den vielen dingen die wir zu kritisieren
haben geht das manchmal unter 2
der bundesinnenminister hat heute im
kabinett vorgetragen über die reform des
bundesamtes für bevölkerungsschutz
ich glaube dieses bundesamt ist richtig
dass es ist richtig dass es da ist aber
es hat ein schatten dasein geführt und
seine potenziale nicht sozusagen
gelebt und gezeigt mit der form glaube
ich haben wir jetzt ein sehr viel
besseres instrumentarium das wird auf
vielen ebenen anfang von den serien
alarm und apps die dazu zu installieren
sind bis hin zu präsentieren fähigkeiten
auch für mögliche zukünftige pandemie
für mich ein schlüsselpunkt allerdings
ist das was wir auch im zusammenhang mit
der mpk immer wieder diskutieren
es muss die schnittstelle zwischen
länder verantwortung und bundes
verantwortung besser sozusagen in den
blick genommen werden und dass da
angeknüpft wird an das was wir auch in
den strukturen für die gemeinsame
terrorismusbekämpfung zum beispiel haben
ständige immer arbeitende täglich
zusammenkommen die taskforce oder oder
eben einheiten von bund und ländern die
sich mit diesen fragen gemeinsam
beschäftigen damit auch eine gemeinsame
kultur der durch das durch lebens einer
solchen pandemie entsteht das halte ich
vielleicht für den wichtigsten punkt in
diesen vor reformvorhaben für dieses
bundesamt irgendwie nachfrage gewinnt
wenn sie gestatten
das ist wahrscheinlich eine sehr
wesentliche punkte alle kollegen und
kollegen die sich bereits zivilschutz
ausgehende bevölkerungsschutz aber auch
natürlich der reform der
sicherheitsbehörden stoßen natürlich
immer wieder in die frage der bund
länder zusammenarbeit gestellt sich dann
ganz ohne weg und ich glaube den letzten
jahren sind viele hre vor mitunter auch
ehrlicherweise gescheitert war in den
ländern unabhängig der parteipolitischen
farbe der ein gewisser widerstand auch
gegenüber reformanstrengungen
reformbewegungen die es hier im
parlament gab gab es ein widerstand wie
glauben sie dass vielleicht auch durch
diese corona pandemie ein neuer geist
der zusammenarbeit entstehen könnte
zwischen bund und land
man kann er die ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen kritisieren aber man kann
vielleicht feststellen dass es eine
plattform ist wo bund und länder sich
wirklich mit dem ziel vereinbaren
einheitliche gemeinsame regelung zu
schaffen das ist ja ein guter ansatz
anstatt wenn wir 16 verschiedene
regelungen in diesem land haben das
würde wahrscheinlich noch mehr
durcheinander und chaos führen
deswegen meine frage wie glauben sie
wird sich dieser geist künftig mit
hinblick auf den bevölkerungsschutz und
gemeinsame lagebilder gemeinde
die zentren entwickeln ich kann hier nur
eine hoffnung äußern
um diese hoffnung muss sein dass neben
dem stolz der länder auf ihre
eigenständigkeit der berechtigt ist und
der uns auch stark macht weil das dazu
vielfalt kommt doch auch die die
tatsache berücksichtigung findet dass
wir heute in einer globalen situation
leben in der mehr krisen auftreten als
das vielleicht früher der fall war und
dass fast keine dieser krisen
lokalisiert werden kann auf ein
bundesland oder eine kommune sondern
meistens sogar noch das bundesgebiet
übersteigen und wir merken wir ja auch
an der notwendigkeit europäisch
einheitlich zu handeln das muss mehr in
den blick genommen werden und dass
deshalb nicht fragen sozusagen der
zuständigkeit permanent eine rolle
spielen sondern fragen der des der best
practice dass man sich darüber
austauscht dass man bereit ist offen mit
anderen auch zu fahren denn ich glaube
wir haben hier große fortschritte
gemacht ob das das online zugangs gesetz
ist ob das aber auch die gemeinsame
terrorismus bekämpfung des islamismus
bekämpfung und so weiter und so fort
aber es wir sind längst noch nicht am
ende und wir müssen da noch viele
hinzufügen ansonsten wird unser land
nicht widerstandsfähig genug sein um die
auf uns zukommen den krisen der zukunft
zu bewältigen
fabio die marge die linke stellt die
nächste frage liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer so weit also die fragestunde
aus dem deutschen bundestag wir möchten
das gerne in der analyse von unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten aus berlin der
auch dazu auskunft geben kann lieber
thomas wie das jetzt einzuschätzen ist
was wir da in den letzten minuten gehört
haben die kanzlerin hat ihre
entschuldigung noch einmal wiederholt
und ist auf harsche kritik auch der
opposition eingegangen thomas kannst du
das noch mal zusammenfassen für uns
bitte ja es ging damit los dass angela
merkel quasi wortgleich noch einmal die
entschuldigung wiederholt hatte sie ein
paar minuten vorher im bundeskanzleramt
vor der presse verlesen hat auch in der
gleichen stimmung was er sagen in diesen
an gefassten
durchaus auch in gewisser weise
demütigen fehler eingestehen
das ist in ihrer eigenen fraktion und
beim koalitionspartner sehr gut
angekommen die oppositionsparteien waren
davon
weniger beeindruckt dietmar bartsch der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linkspartei hat
in der tat merkel gefragt ob sie denn
nicht die vertrauensfrage stellen will
ob sie ihr rückhalt in ihrer eigenen
fraktion habe da gab es war eigentlich
eine der wenigen momente wo es wirklich
dann auch richtig hoch her ging im
parlament zwischen unions fraktion und
der linken
da ging es auch um die performance der
unionsminister in dieser pandemie auch
das war immer wieder ein thema es wurden
dann ein bisschen muss man sagen
sozusagen die die dauerbrenner bei
gewissen themen im parlament dann auch
wieder gespielt die fdp auch die grünen
beharrten und wiederholte noch einmal
den wunsch dass die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nicht diese
zentrale dominierende rolle spielen soll
sondern dass das parlament das die
gewählte volksvertretung
da nicht mehr als das gremium informiert
wird sondern eben die entscheidung dass
die entscheidung dort getroffen werden
und auch dort debattiert werden
marco buschmann der geschäftsführer der
fdp fraktion sagt zum beispiel wann
hören sie denn auf spätnachts und
übermüdet mikro management zu betreiben
das ist in der tat eine der fragen die
man sich dann nach dieser letzten mpk
stellen muss und die wahrscheinlich sich
auch angela merkel gestellt hat da sie
ja heute diesen fehler mit den oster
ruhetage eingeräumt hat für die sie wie
wir hier in den agenturen lesen auch
außerhalb des parlaments große
zustimmung bekommt die autoindustrie zum
beispiel sagt das waren die richtige
entscheidung der zentralverband des
deutschen handwerks sagt dass der städte
und gemeindebund hat das geäußert so
würde sonst ein gewaltiger zusätzlicher
ansturm im lebensmittelhandel entstanden
sein
der deutsche handelsverband hde also
fast aus allen branchen kommt da quasi
zustimmung thomas ist nur die frage
inwiefern das reicht zu sagen wir haben
da einen fehler gemacht diese
entscheidung wäre nicht die richtige
gewesen
an der stelle sorry aber muss da noch
mehr kommen und
wenn ja was also es ist zumindest ein
erster schritt und man sieht es in der
tat bei den reaktionen aber sicher auch
bei den reaktionen die du vorher aus dem
chat vorgetragen hast das kommt erst mal
gut an fehler einzugestehen ist etwas
was wichtig ist und wenn die
bundeskanzlerin das macht kann man nur
hoffen dass eine gewisse fehlerkultur
die auch wichtig ist um eine pandemie zu
bekämpfen dann vielleicht auch bei
unteren ebenen dann wichtig wird aber
natürlich ist das nur ein erster schritt
die bundesregierung und die
ministerpräsidenten haben auch beim
letzten beschluss gezeigt dass sie von
den bürgern relativ wie fordern mit
strengen verordnungen von den
unternehmen von selbstständigen viel
einfordern was manche an die existenz
der existenzgrundlagen darum bringt aber
umgekehrt oft nicht in der lage sind
ihrerseits zu liefern eben beim impfen
oder bei der bereitstellung von genügend
test und da geht eben dann das sieht man
in den umfragen und sieht man den
verlauf dieses pandemie jahres da geht
viel gefolgschaft verloren
und da reicht fehler eingestehen eben
alleine nichts und da ist es nun
wirklich am punkt ist dann am ende
natürlich auch besser zu machen
es gab zwei interessante punkte in
dieser frage stunde wo merkel in
gewisser weise dann auch ihre grenzen
aufgezeigt hat was besser machen angeht
sie hat an einer stelle gesagt wir
müssen uns überlegen inwieweit wir
solchen großen herausforderungen solchen
großen krisen mit unserer föderalen
ordnung wirklich gewachsen sind das sind
krisen die weit über das bundesgebiet
ihr noch hinausreichen
und wir müssen uns für die zukunft
überlegen wie wir uns diesen besser
stellen können dass wir weniger die
frage der zuständigkeit so sagt es die
ins zentrum stellen sondern best
practice also dass wenn ich ihn
bemerkenswert weil es in der tat auch
eine der der großen hindernisse in der
bekämpfung der pandemie ist das immer
auf die jeweils andere ebene gezeigt
wird und der fehler dann immer auf den
anderen abgesetzt wird wir haben das
eben in der fragestunde auch noch mehr
belegt da waren natürlich selbst daran
beteiligt
bei der frage warum denn nicht genügend
tests in den schulen ankommen hat sie
gesagt wir als bundesregierung gestellt
doch genug bereit und wenn den ländern
dass vätern sollen die sich melden dann
bestellen sie noch mehr am ende aber ist
es so dass in den schulen kitas da wo
die ist es dringend gebraucht werden die
empfehlen
es ist wieder so eine frage der
zuständigkeiten wo dringender
handlungsbedarf ist und wo es
wahrscheinlich genauso ist wie ich die
kanzlerin selbst sagte an anderer stelle
best practice ist er wichtiger als die
frage der zuständigkeit
nun war es ja auch bei dieser frage nach
ostern so dass das eine idee von angela
merkel gewesen dass offenbar der aber
dann die ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten jahr gefolgt sind
einen von ihnen wollen wir mal gerade
hören das ist sachsens ministerpräsident
michael kretschmer der auch einer von
denen gewalt der gesagt hat das ist zwar
eine unpopuläre maßnahme aber sie ist
notwendig heute nun hat er sich hinter
die kanzlerin gestellt die diese
regelung wieder zurück genommen hat und
die kanzlerin verteidigt wir hört mal
rein
ich finde sie muss dafür nicht die
verantwortung übernehmen
diese entscheidung ist von 16
ministerpräsidenten und der
bundesregierung gemeinsam getroffen
worden
in dem gemeinsamen bewusstsein dass
aktuell eine exponentielle entwicklung
in dieser coroner situation stattfindet
tja so weit also das kurze statement von
michael kretschmer ähnliche statements
gibt es auch aus anderen bundesländern
aus hamburg zum beispiel hört man vom
regierenden dort ähnliches aber thomas
erstens sie haben das alle mitgetragen
das war keine alleinige entscheidung und
zweitens eigentlich hat man ja vor ein
paar wochen gesagt man zieht die
notbremse
wenn in den einzelnen regionen die
inzidenz über 100 ist auch das hat der
kretschmann zum beispiel mitgetragen nun
liegt die inzidenz in sachsen seit einer
ganzen weile bei über 100 deutlich im
moment liegt sie bei 154,9 glaube ich
und trotzdem hat das sächsische
sozialministerium entschieden nein wir
ziehen die notbremse nicht das müssen
die kommunen selber machen das heißt wir
erleben ein abweichen von den
beschlüssen die getroffen wurden und
auch das hat die kanzlerin ja eben noch
einmal angesprochen und darauf
hingewiesen wir müssen diese
notbremse die wir selbst beschlossen
haben ernst nehmen wenn die kanzlerin
sagt ich habe fehler gemacht wie
reagieren denn dann jetzt die
ministerpräsidenten die reagieren so wie
wir es gerade bei kretschmer gesehen
haben auch armin laschet der
ministerpräsident von nrw hat sich so
ähnlich geäußert aber es ist genau der
punkt den du ansprichst werden in langen
nächtlichen sitzungen da beschlüsse
getroffen die notbremse ist das aller
beste beispiel dafür
und gestern abend bzw in dieser nacht
von montag auf dienstag wird von von
angela merkel der satz überliefert dass
man über diesen automatismus der not
drin wenn sich jemand einem treffen
zuvor ja schon vereinbart hatte dass man
nur rund um den nun noch einmal ringen
muss also das ist ein grundproblem
dieser ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
im grunde der ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten an sich dass sie
sich nicht an beschlüsse halten die sie
in stundenlangen nachtsitzung sitzungen
sich gegenseitig abbringen
die notbremse ist eigentlich relativ
klar sie tritt automatisch in kraft
stents mit 100 und insofern ist es
völlig unverständlich zb warum in
sachsen oder in anderen kommunen und
landkreisen dann ausnahmeregelungen
geschaffen werden oder eben diese
automatismus da nicht gilt
da fragt man sich dann schon warum es
überhaupt solche lange sitzungen braucht
und ob man nicht andere wege finden muss
um ein effektives und auf berechenbare
sie auch für die bevölkerung
berechenbares krisen-management finden
zu können
thomas jetzt habe ich leider gottes das
ende deiner antwort verpasst aber ich
würde gerne noch eine frage aus dem chat
aufgreifen über youtube da erkundigt
sich jemand den ich jetzt leider gerade
nicht mehr finde er möge es mir
verzeihen
nach einem möglichen rücktritt von jens
spahn
das ist die erste frage die ich hätte
und die zweite ist weil ich schon eine
ahnung haben du sie beantworten wird
warum fällt es denn der kanzlerin so
leicht fehler einzugestehen und anderen
im kabinett nicht
das ist eine so einfache wie schwierige
frage ich glaube dass das angela merkel
natürlich dass aus einer meiner position
heraus macht wofür sie absehbar ist dass
sie in etwa einem halben jahr nicht mehr
bundeskanzlerin sein wird und wo sie
selbst in dieser historischen krise
natürlich auch darauf achtet was ihr
erbe sein die sie in den
geschichtsbüchern erinnert wird und wie
letztlich auch ihr corona management
beurteilt wird das ist eine
entscheidende phase
mit welchem gefühl mit welcher botschaft
und auch mit welcher stimmung sie am
ende das kanzleramt verlässt man muss ja
sagen zum als erste kanzlerin auch
freiwillig dann dieses amt verlässt
nicht abgewählt wird oder ersetzt wird
und das ist etwas was was ihr in dieser
situation zumindest eine gewisse stärke
gibt
außerdem hat hier glaube ich ein klares
politisches gespür auch ein
machtinstinkt zu wissen dass sie in
dieser situation nur etwas gewinnen kann
durch die politische flucht nach vorne
den fehler einzugestehen und zwar
schnell und ist auch schnell zu
korrigieren so hat sich selbst in diesen
beiden staaten das im kanzleramt und
eben im bundestag ja auch gesagt weil
entspannt zum beispiel ist die situation
eine völlig andere er ist dann beginn
seiner politischen karriere hat sogar
schon ausgelotet kurz vor der wahl von
armin laschet zum cdu-vorsitzenden ob es
nicht für ihn schon jetzt schon zeit
wäre
am kanzleramt anzuklopfen weil entspannt
ist es eher das prinzip ja keine fehler
einzugestehen ja sich sozusagen da
nichts an haften zu lassen was ihn in
seiner politischen arbeit da immer
begleitet einen moment das man immer
wieder beobachtet dass bei pannen und
fehlern in der regel andere oder andere
zuständigkeiten dann dafür daran schuld
sind
aber wie gesagt das hat möglicherweise
auch mit der unterschiedlichen geografie
einerseits und mit der unterschiedlichen
position in der jeweiligen politischen
karriere zu tun dass beide spanien
merkel da so unterschiedlich reagieren
thomas reichert vielen dank für deine
einschätzungen mit einer allerletzten
frage würde ich gerne hier den sack
zumachen braindead fragt muss man morgen
zur schule also das kommt darauf an
liebe bringt wo du oder sie gerade sagte
ist in welchen regionen in welchen
landkreis ich kann das sozusagen von von
von brandenburg und berlin aussagen es
gibt die präsenzpflicht ist ja dort
aufgehoben da muss man nicht zur schule
dort kann man noch zur schule gehen
aber die regelungen die die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz der in der
nacht auf dienstag geschlossen hat die
sehen vor dass bei instanzen über 100
ausreichend getestet werden musste mit
schulen offen sind und ab einer inzidenz
ab 200 die schule schließen müssen
das sind regelungen der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die jetzt
von den ländern und dann wieder von den
kultusministerien umgesetzt werden
müssen so ist leider das föderale
prinzip dass das immer noch eine weile
dauert und deswegen ist auch eine
antwort auf eine so einfache frage wie
diese leider ziemlich kompliziert und
wir müssen darauf vermutlich noch ein
paar tage auch abwarten und die
vereinfachte antwort generell muss
natürlich sein schule es immer egal ob
pandemie oder nicht ob nun zu hause oder
in der schule oder online oder irgendwie
nur wenn ferien sind dann ist keine
schule oder wenn ein oster ruhetag
gewesen wäre aber den gibt es nun mal
nicht
vielen dank für ihre zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer fragen und lieben dank thomas
reich hat für diese einschätzung an die
sind wirklich sehr turbulenten tag heute
der sicherlich noch turbulent weiter
gehen wird wir bleiben natürlich bei zdf
heute live für sie am ball die zdf heute
sowieso und heute abend gibt es außerdem
ein zdf spezial um 1925 direkt im
anschluss an die 19 uhr heute sendung
bleiben sie dran haben sie trotz allem
einen schönen tag